[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up what's up everyone welcome to
the dragon ball fighterz online take
kaichi master event for europe one that
is france belgium and switzerland i'm
damascus and i'm joined by man like c4
for what is going to be probably the
most attacked topic we've got on the
tenkaichi even so far c4
yeah yeah yeah you uh showed me the
smash cg and i was like damn this is
this is going to be crazy crazy crazy
crazy plays that we've seen for a long
time in eu
but on this stage where they're playing
for now
it's going to be
a good slog
yeah it's going to be kind of ridiculous
we got a ton guys it's an entire top 8
that we are going to run through today
and this is the brackets that we are
about to go through we got kane versus
kasuga we got the vesprim
versus no card then on the loser side we
got june alago versus hazel and
silverblades versus chomp i think
supervisor chomp is the highlight match
of this round one c4 man yeah yeah yeah
john's changed his team a bit but uh
those two players always bring the
interesting stuff the interesting tech
the interesting characters it's gonna be
so sick seeing what they've come up with
uh
for the for the world championship i'm
gonna be super interested yeah that is
absolutely uh ridiculous and an entirely
a french top eight that you can uh you
could argue silver blade so silver blade
is of
swiss citizenship and lives in france so
he's got the flag option select like me
i'm french i live in the uk i can use
both at will you know whenever i feel
like it uh that's what we do but of
course guys this is the dragon ball
fighters world championship and i've
seen a lot of you guys in chat already
we're writing we're like oh what's this
event that's online that offline there's
plenty of things there are plenty of
things guys to know about this the
dragon ball fighters world championship
let me just quickly run through uh
through everything with you guys it is a
three-tiered tournament that is
happening for nowadays the online
challenge until mid-november then the
regional finals will be in december and
then the world final uh will be early
2022 of course regional finals and final
are both gonna be offline these at the
moment are the online qualifiers for the
offline finals there are two tiers of
online qualifiers the major ones like
today the master one and the tenkaichi
online challenges that can pretty much
be run by any to out there if you want
to run a tournament and be there you can
definitely join and be there and this is
the most important c4 the points
breakdown as today as you can see on
most of the 10k online challenges you
can get at most 100 points and that's if
you get 64 or more players and at the
moment the only regions
do you know who are the only regions who
got more than 64 players c4 i actually
don't know
east coast of course
just like chelsea and lbc
yeah
and
brazil
brazil gets 70 players in the tournament
it's kind of ridiculous man
[Laughter]
we are
listen like there are a lot of players
out there in the world and of course a
lot of points on the line in different
regions plenty of uh
plenty like there are different
qualifiers for different regions but
today uh we got 200 points on the line
it's all on pc and ps4 today's event is
on pc and these are all of the arenas
that are uh available for you guys of
course we already run through quite a
few a day this is the second to last
tournament japan europe one which is
france belgium and switzerland uh europe
too we've run throughout purity you have
a prison for the north america west
america east brazil mexico australia and
middle east as for the regional finals
this these are the weekends you guys
should take off i'm taking this weekend
off because i'm gonna be in paris for
this uh for the fifth of december the
original finals europe 11th and 12th the
original finals usa 18th and 19th the
regional finals in japan all of these
are going to be offline there are 12
players per original finals eight of
them are invited if you guys have been
following along on the twitter all of
them have been announced and this is why
the players are not going to see today
for example wawa he's already invited
for the finals
i don't need to enter today giving you
know a chance to other players all three
of them have been unveiled already on
the bandai namco esports uh twitter and
the way the original finals breakdown
will work is we are going to define a
top four player
for each of the regional
top four for each of the royal finals
and first for mexico australia brazil
and middle east all of these
will go to the
regional to the war finals sorry early
2022 c4 a world
final offline
with the best around the globe man this
mad
this year's been a bit of a madness i
didn't expect this to happen but
thank the zenos they brought us this man
this is going to be not just the finals
the build up the build up to the finals
has been super hyped yeah absolutely
it's uh i'm absolutely uh looking
forward to this one and of course the
registrations are open on dragon ball
fighters esports portal and if you are a
to and you want to run an event uh you
can still you know apply and run events
there are plenty of these events around
and of course a lot of these leagues are
uh already like active and everything
i'm thinking about like japan for
example ikon is number one by far you
know in japan right now but the one
that's uh interesting us right now is
obviously the france switzerland and
belgium uh like region and at the moment
this one is tied because let's be a ton
of talented players are in this region
and at the moment the number one is kane
with 145 points and the second one is
silver blades with 100 points so these
two are really close to each other and
both of them need to perform today i
think k needs to make sure he's in front
of silver blades but
if both of them don't do well today and
someone like kasuga vesprim noka they
already have points ends up winning the
tournament that might be the end for the
guys
yeah yeah we've said this in pretty much
uh all of the
pencatchy events the point differential
between like first the third is massive
and even entering your locals
might not make it up you have to smoke
everyone in your locals and you're gonna
have to have a turnout like you said
like brazil
with 64 players and if you don't have
that
that 100 point gap between first and
second is paramount to getting into uh
to qualify yeah it is uh it's massive of
course france has a ton of tournaments
reza
runs a lot of them and a lot of these
players are grinding them to get the
points and okay and of course is there
and hungry uh to get there and we will
most likely see a lot of him today but
our first game is ready guys remember
this is the top 8 bracket we're going to
start with kane versus kasuga
vespry versus no connects then june
lagos hazel and silver blades versus
trump all of these are first to two and
the top four will be in first two uh
three
the players are ready and in the lobby
and i am curious to see what soldiers
say of course kasuga well known for the
team uh casual angels you know the team
bathwater the team i only pick female
characters this is kasuga
all i'm praying is that kane doesn't
happy birthday casper i'm gonna have to
meet my mic
[Laughter]
mine's gonna be like happy
no
no
fingers crossed guys don't get happy
birthday casper good for my for my
career oh yeah kane's team
ssj goodyear for careful of genema we've
seen him play so many different teams
right we've seen him use the seven team
back in the day with the go tanks really
clean his construction of synergy is so
good so
we've seen him with his genema and he
thinks your number's really strong oh
yeah and obviously everyone's fallen
victim to ssh and goku right there big
second fought yeah though it'll be
interesting to see what he does and how
kasuga's labs against it because he must
have left defense against his team for
sure absolutely this is one that you
need to work with but kane with a strong
start putting casual guy immediately
into the corner not gonna use china
buses just yet keeping it for the
pressure oh the history decay betraying
him more mix the barian casual escapes
here we go jumping over the assist
chasing stairs
it's the hit
probably going to get the corner jk le
mao xd
i i didn't even see that drone rush
coming man
yeah i mean that's the classic right
it's the classic it doesn't help when
the back of the stage is green as well
yeah i swear i was like oh hold up i got
hit i don't know about you guys
personally speaking i am losing this
bracket already but kasuga bring it he
don't get the left right of course in
the corner cain's gonna block the
challenge after the 6m oh no bad
reflects by kasuga and kane is gonna get
his opening probably gonna tag out that
super saiyan forgojita
probably but uh yeah this is a lot of
damage from a guest reflect gonna get
their level three the hardest will knock
downs kept last
spin in the bar and there's cassie the
spark i mean this knockdown isn't too
potent but there's a genimbraces behind
it this is the scary bit yeah it's a c
assist as well so it's uh number 6 it's
also like 50 frames or a blockstone you
get eight oh my god 5 ll
working like this
vasquez you know we could over here
offensive spacing
listen you may not like it but this is
what peak performance looks like
you can press
it's square button on ps4 it's x on xbox
it's y on the switch
i think it's the u key on the on
keyboard if you're going keyboards just
just press it man you got that button
why not it's the perfect whiff
punishment
they're not looking for it's the perfect
one exactly
that was an interesting ground start the
two one for l
from casual and casual gets the
supernatural
not gonna get a ton of damage i'm just
gonna go for the dragon rush and get
some guaranteed pressure on this oh
decides to not activate
that android 17 and that should be
enough to kill janemba
yeah the smokes are mirror mix-ups man
everyone's ready for like 17 to ping you
down and when it doesn't happen you're
just the deer in the headlights yeah
absolutely all right kasuga opening it
up but there is still a spark on cane
side round start super dash
let's go
here we go the standard mix up blocks
the lowest sparks carry on
good snipe though kasich not deciding to
cancel out the barrier gets clicked for
his troubles not much damage but the
momentum the meter builds and the spark
is scary
but reflects but
i don't think i don't think he can get
enough anyway for this so he's just
going to extend as much as he can
hold up we're extending a bit more with
vegeta oh no that was i'm not sure what
was the plan but you know what the plan
is an optimal kill you don't use as much
meter as you should have used optimal
meter use
meter efficient man
this is how we do this is how we do we
bargain hunt out here
this is one though passive is definitely
not out it's the heat
a good one from castle i might choose
that level free to pin him down no
simple oh the back dash on wake up got
to watch out oh
casual garcia domingo de barcelona
he swapped flags real quick to the
spanish one and that level three is
gonna take that gogeta out and it's
going to be a kefla versus kefla to the
side of game number one
he spoke about the silver blades os with
the two flags kasich has got that team
he's got that too run up me gets the hit
lane k no
i'm the kepler master
it's a knock down are we going to spend
three bars again yes we are indeed right
mix behind this of course not the
massive mix it's mostly a high low that
you can get of this but of course still
you could go for row 6h you could go for
a row dragon rush anything one not sure
that's what he wanted he probably
dropped the dash there kane is forced to
block all right keeps the plus frames
there kane is going to put the pressure
you know 6h might come so kane is trying
to not be too obvious about this one and
cast your guys blocking good reflects
on the reflect
from kane
he's dead
confirms
we come back
and he is going
to get a game number one
of this one despite kane being on the
lead quite early
exactly exactly that was freaking i'm
telling you man castle has been training
a lot as of late the last couple of
weeks streaming playing grinding it's
paying off for someone like kane to be
your opponent in winner's side it's got
to be kind of daunting but good start
right one up to castle yep all right but
kane this time once again gets the early
opening the pressure with super saiyan
forgojita i'm not sure what kasuga did
but what he did is
uh sign that kefla's death that should
be enough for kane to finish the combo
level one into level one and that's a
dead key flakkain coming back really
quick
yeah spending two bars like he said
bringing in their own kevlar but like
you said we've seen castle make this
comeback before it is not off the cards
18. technically i guess captain just got
two and a half
right now though the forehead is getting
beat the virus whoa whoa whoa chill out
everyone everyone calm down well he got
to hit a bit of that gojita watch out
who came with the pickup kane is
smelling blood right now listen he's
angry that he dropped that first game
and he's going to put a ton of pressure
on casual gas android 18 what's the mix
gonna be 6m he's gonna be blocked by the
tap the air he's gonna open him up and
that should be enough to get the kill
yeah i'm standing with a c assist oh
that's so sweet
that was a clean extension if i've ever
seen one man
yo ain't literally kenzie's wearing a
weave bruh he's got the best extensions
that was crazy damage just saying that's
that's on his way to a perfect
not a halal perfect because he hit
gojitas just earlier but still perfect
in my books
indeed hit him down with the kicks
[Music]
okay got the tail normals
oh
wait he did five l but
she completely won this i guess kane did
not press through the right timing
casper is gonna take some momentum
yeah he's gonna go for a level three
we're gonna eat up a little bit blue
health's gonna get recovered here as
well
not nothing to uh be sad about but can
you block the left right you just go for
spark keep the whole team intact doesn't
need to not going through yeah that was
not the the deepest of the left right
and good one uses genemba to lock her
down and there is no assist right now so
kane will have to reset his block string
at some point
indeed and they are coming back but very
slowly obviously january said to see
assist castle got time to fight back
gets out of the corner at least just to
play a little bit neutral not much bar
but does have spot
that supernash was very close to being
cursed man i swear she was about to get
behind and be like surprise supernash
works as intended
all right here's the knock down
him an equalizer
classic
i don't even need to spark on this it's
more than enough as long as payne
finishes the combo we will know and we
never know
nice one gets the genuine beats
and it's one one in this wino semi-final
one
game away from
a ticket to wino's final and this one
was
super dominant mankind definitely turned
angry
yeah yeah he didn't get touched until uh
passage was down to his last character
so
something
something that kane's gonna take forward
into the next match castle guy has to
not let it phase them though right
they've gotta stay focused and go i did
it one match i just got you one more
time good snipe 360 no scope
oh what a challenge
we don't respect frames out there
great starts
like us
man's not scared looking at and going
straight to offense gonna pay your free
bars you call the bro of course you do
spend it
gonna get the left right yeah one of the
level threes that take you out of the
corner it's gonna be potent
yeah you get the mix behind this
regardless kane is blocking right now
what do you got for us oh no that was a
terrible guard council came kasugawa's
wait ready for this and kasuga
completely dominance at the start what
an escape
yeah oh no oh no everyone's favorite c4
don't say it
two goals one two
are currently being hit by kane but that
was a terrible combo he's getting the
extension regardless
let's see oh no kane oh no
wait where did kengo
i don't think he himself knows all right
have to extend it to tom right now
that should be enough
yes
that was a ton of drops
it was
kane came out on top of something that
we've seen him do time and time again
right he doesn't need to finish combos
to finish the match but right now kasim
has got a fight in charge he's going to
do the comeback it's the dragon rush
going to build a bag of metal nothing
able to kill though but the position is
not too bad
oh no my goodness
damascus what's going on in this last
match
how do you even convert on this one but
the tail and that's gonna be amazing
because that's gonna get that super sun
for gogeta out big mistake
by kane
giving kasuga a character and now it's
even get a snack
what's on the menu
of course it's france
munchin
you know what he deserves it he deserves
it she's gonna make this comeback she
needs to eat
fish with the tail
this woman oh no oh no
that was an early happy birthday but
jennifer did not completely lock them
down so that is going to be kane putting
them into the corner and that's gonna be
level three now and now there's a
question spark on the spot
i think that's a good he's got a spark
right
uh
he gets a spark
yeah yeah
and that's that's
a semi win i won't say for kane because
it's park level two but that mix was a
bit too potent he's building a ton of
meter that should be a dead keflam kane
now has to rely
on geneva with spark to build a general
which sparks an absolute beast
but he needs to take two characters down
oh fish off the show someone obviously
like yourself is your name a connoisseur
and a geneva enjoyer who know the
benefits of having geneva we can't block
the left right it's irrelevant going to
be about half
health possibly do you keep i was about
to say if you bring in
a lady mrs 21 to get the left right or
do you bait the spark that's got to be
on the card here right
yeah of course oh my god no way that was
a two layers spark bait from kasuga can
he get enough to get the kill
yes spark is gonna save him
i believe spark saves him all right kane
okay you cannot get hit once right now
trying to get out all right getting out
of the corner trying to keep some more
pressure
oh
the mask oh no oh
that is dead the spark is going to run
out but considering janemba's damage
output he can one touch uh android 21
anytime right now uh but
casual trying to gonna try to be
[Music]
that was almost full screen
press one if you got hit
look look c4 is camera got hit
i have no idea the c4 camera is doing
the tyrant cosplay yeah yeah this is
glitching out
it had to be good that was that that was
almost a glitch man was in plus like how
how plus is that fireball
it's about 30 plus frames right plus 30
squats
oh come on man cats you got
that
was that was a bit too much man
that was a bit too much um
i was not expecting
i was not expecting that one
and kane was not either kasuga
is going
to
qualify to that winners final of course
man we i feel like there is no favorite
there is no favorite in this tournament
man casual moving forwards and you know
what that's gonna be a potentially
extremely juicy
loser's quarterfinal as kane
might have to face well his number one
rivaling points silver blades quite
early in the bracket which means whoever
wins this could potentially just
completely take his opponent out of the
entire race
yeah i kind of like it it's cool it's
sort of like
poetry if silver blades has to go up
against kate it loses side
because then they basically seal their
fate like you said they're very close in
points and
it's a great idea
yeah if kane stayed on the top
silverblade would have to hope other
people to be king but now his fate is in
his own hands that is exactly how you
want any tournament to go like so this
means that there is one person between
cane and silver blades uh
that can that will only get 45 points if
not if not less you know depending on
whether silver blades makes it right
and and you can see the point spread 45
points for fifth if the if whoever moves
forward goes all the way to first or
seconds that's an amazing situation so
this despite kane not being in windows
final
might be a bit of luck
for him right now but
damn i mean an unexpected start i want
to say on this
kane losing to kasuga kasuga in winona's
final we're gonna move the second
semi-final the spring versus nokia i
know a lot of guys know about noka but
this vesprimiz is one of the very best
in france he didn't have the opportunity
to travel or anything but he's a guy who
keeps consistently beating the best i've
seen him beating kane in some of the
tenkaichi online events as well he's
always always here to destroy brackets
yeah i think like the spread of these uh
top eights i think four of them are well
known like kane kasugar uh silver blades
i think he's pretty well known and
obviously nokia very old school the
other four we know people eu know about
them and i'm happy they get to shine and
showcase their skill dress for him like
you said he he's taken out these top
heads he's definitely done it before um
so yeah
i don't want to spoil anything he's just
got to watch his play his team looks
super
super super like
pink square i'm just trying to get
points but he plays it super well super
super well yeah this is this is an
optimal team i mean both of these teams
are quite optimal considering the meta
continuing the tier list considering
everything uh we got noka uh with his
kid boo super son for gogeta and ui goku
and the stream with kid buu ui goku and
z broly
i'm scared
the the big boy and you know what's
really weird i think i've said this
before and one of the other ones uh
tenkaichi tournaments is z broly over
here isn't actually that popular nope
it's quite rare
to see a french player have zebroly like
actually mainzy broly is very rare uh
chomp is one of the other players that
has a zebra on a team yeah well it's not
something you see too often on this side
of the pond yeah it's okay we're just
catering to our american audience with
this match
right now yeah
but that's true like zebral is
surprisingly is not that popular uh best
friend is probably the best like zebraly
player in europe uh right now and he's
going to try and put the pressure on but
at the moment it's noka and not his kid
boo but his ube putting the pressure in
yeah we have to put respect on it and
just like you're saying about z broly
being western's best character
when it comes to france i think nokia
might have the best kid who's so optimal
it mixes up us venomous not even potent
venomous there's so nice and he's still
got two touches they keep knocking his
character and he's still got two types
of it it absolutely works man and listen
noka is one of these guys who have been
you know blessed by the meta it's like
oh i like it as a character before the
game was even released like yeah i'm
gonna play kid who i like the character
turns out arxis was like well i hope you
like winning too because this is kibbu
for you
hand in hand oh the late idea the master
i think he's gonna smoke restrooms you i
if you can finish this combo
no car
nice
i like it because nokia did the super in
the air he is literally infamous of
dropping to the ground and getting
dressed for the super so i'm glad he's
got a character that's going air level
one it is one of the the local specials
on this one let's see if i feel version
oh no i think you want it to reflect but
probably not do it correctly it's gonna
get hit by that asc is not gonna be
enough to kill i believe from uh no
cards there he's just gonna extend not
building a third box
unfortunate
but still gets the pressure oh my gosh
knock knock who's there
i'm here
shut up
stop
i don't want to block anymore man same
side i don't care super dash option
select
you said it perfectly that's all it was
layers layered all faces covered dragon
rush getting that blue health why not an
aggressive there by mocha just going for
the super that's straight in his face
look at me
look at me
you were the top tier before i'm the top
tier now
look at me okay it's okay but now so
zebraly will spark so noka will have to
do the comeback on the screen uh we wish
him luck
right now breaking zebra these anchors
with the left right iad shenanigans
shout back at them man like ube getting
a little free
where are we going instant spark
possibly
let's see
that should be enough the spring is
saving spark for
for
for grand finals
[Applause]
yeah
it looks like it i mean
i don't want to be the guy that said i
told you so but i told you so spark
instantly don't live don't let no cars
smell your fear you'll just take
advantage like that you've got to be
quick on your decisions you can't wait
dragon rush free
pre-ordained he was doing that drag rush
before you got up yeah yeah he was like
i don't care you wanna spark spark you
don't park goodbye yeah exactly putting
the pressure on but let's see another
strong start by luca and this cream is
absolutely struggling in this match it's
been entirely in luca's favor
yeah and you know what bespoke fireman
waking up with buttons i know vesperon
has the players very
very much neutral heavy based especially
with kimbu that really works and the
assistant's got but now he's gonna have
to turn on the pressure
but you know what no kiss the plumber
bro
yep that's going to be completely
stopped and ui goku
putting that kibble down what's going
with the pressure yeah the reflecting to
bro tank and he successfully blocked the
left arm of the forbidden one
oh it's kind of framed up with the broly
assist there preston's gonna take that
with the receipt put him in the corner
look gonna spend any bath nice bait
let's go
it's the buttons
in the words of the infamous format
damascus mid mid mid
oh we got more means
let's let him rip
oh just to get the extension
unfortunately x ball keeps him pinned
down because
no one's that blow your nose
that was an interestingly weird decision
for me but let's see the pressure is on
and that is going to be a dead kid with
spring finally
getting some momentum
and looking a bit better right now
he still got smart
yeah that's definitely the saving grace
i think there's definitely an argument
to have about uh being a character down
or having spark intact no could we both
of those
but still solid at the moment preston
does open one of the overheads gonna
take him to the corner where we're gonna
go from here though damascus
no not yet
do you think i care
it's you're trying to mix me it's my mix
i am i am i am mixing you all right
let's see straight to the spark as well
what yeah
we definitely take those and
there's a lot of bar on the table here i
don't i still don't think they can kill
though right
nah oh no spark run out
[Music]
maybe nah i would
nope and the bro tag is going to save
the stream skill buddha
extension
grab him by the neck
spinning bar now we're going to hold on
to it push him to the corner
2h gets smoked
i'm always surprised that at the the
effective range of that autocombo man
it's like it literally makes coffee
literally makes coffee for you
decaf
oh
blue combos we're getting a showcase of
all the mechanics in the game gets hit
with the windy punch quarter combo once
again
extensions might be able to kill hit the
matches yeah i said instead
i think she wants to put you away goku
anyway yeah
so kid boot into ui goku there and
that's gonna be a dead ui goku noka is
down to his super sign for gojita
to try and join kasuga in wino's final
let's
see yeah one character
a very strong character as we see now
nobody super jumps on the jump confirm
misses that jm and now that's going to
take advantage of that
stop it up his flop is stopping
like
hands shake it
do you shake your opponent's hand after
this sequel
i
i think i have to what was i doing to
get hit by that what did i do to get got
like that make it make sense make it
make sense
maybe holding up i don't know
but all right
let's see the opening goes in nokia's
favor and he's going to immediately put
the pressure on that keyboard but
considering the amount of life he has
left i don't think he had to touch him
just yet before the pickup
is different it's so seasoned right this
is like his day one character
i would like to see noka sniping these
raw tags though because this film keeps
getting away from danger with a road
tike noka has not punished them just yet
maybe
he'll take the time to adapt to us
staircase we're not taking the lift out
there look at this
yeah get the elevators that the
elevators oh he sneezes
but keeping the pressure on oh my god
that is i know that is nothing look at
the left arm of the forbidden one
mid mid mid once again and unfortunately
mocha was
a vest i'm sorry he was clean with it
but didn't actually get him
how much can he find
no i don't think can kill with this
either
i don't think so
all right one touchy
imagine blocking man
foreign concept
for listen if you want blocks there are
other games for this
yeah i've got lego pieces here man
i'm trying to see blocks on my screen
i've got real life blocks i don't need
this that's it just don't walk on them
that's all that's all i can advise you
right now
that's true pain
all right speaking of blocks yeah zebra
is committing to that spark and you know
what that's going to be
a fairly long combo that might eliminate
most of that zivali's park yeah look at
this he's already blinking spark is out
[Music]
maybe a little bit too long
leave my guy alone no no i respect that
i respect that he knows that because so
for those of you who are not familiar
with this right when you hit the assist
because your hits you're hitting your
opponents you can jump cancel your hits
so a lot of times
players who are aware of this will just
jump comes to the move to give some kind
of like spark-ish mix but this dream
knew that the jump would come out and
was ready for that uh yeah
yeah it's like you know what you're
hitting my guy but it won't be in vain
i'm gonna clip you for it but it's all
gone a little bit south because loca
does get rid of the z broly leaving
wrestling with two characters and then
not on a lot of health
yeah it's getting difficult right now
obviously but let's see that ui goku
putting in work both of them are in one
touch uh situations as well so
definitely a hard one trying to go for
the 2h but no good reflect great uh
i don't even know if he needed that
level to you
but might as well be safe because yeah
kid was level 3 is not the best so i go
for it i think i think without level 2
it would have probably be a magic pixel
situation
yeah i agree i agree uh obviously in the
moment you know what he's probably
thinking there's 200 points on the line
let me just make sure you know what i'm
saying yes
another opening got to watch out oh no
that was cheeky
as cheeky as that
i don't know
that's gonna be
dead
look up
you might be
you were about to kill that ui goku
earlier with that keyboard you dropped
the combo
and right now you are down to your final
character
the vesper might join casual guy that
you must find but you know what i'm sure
you don't need much yep level one and
now
it's the true
one touchy
bruh that super dash was super crucial
super effective now is oh sorry no no
it's not it's kick boom
okay
my man roman canceled no
that's it the super dash worked and they
screamed
against all lords i want to say
guess to join kasugar
in that windows final
what
a bunch of games we just had c4
i thought i was here for dragon ball i
definitely saw a jump up brc drift
downwards i'm pretty sure that's what i
saw other than that other than that this
top this
the two winners in top eight i wouldn't
have called it straight up and i know
they're strong but their opponents i
thought would agree but two one on both
sides
like we've been saying this for such a
long time the french community have got
such strong players yeah and the people
we don't see don't think they cut they
can't hang with them they do claim on a
regular basis that's why they're all so
strong but yeah hashtag overcame at
vesper over no car 2-1 a piece shows
that training can pay off for sure
absolutely it's absolutely ridiculous uh
to see this definitely uh to i mean
casual arcane is definitely thing that
you've seen before this cream i know a
lot of you are not familiar with him but
again yeah this is what said right the
depth of talent in in france is is
ridiculous it's like obviously you know
the best of the best in france but
there are a ton of players who are
actually consistently annoying the top
and and all of them are not even there
you know i can think of like falza
recently we've seen psychos and yamas in
paris who've been there doing super well
against like the likes of wade and yasha
and stuff plenty of players are able to
like just completely surprise uh like
any of the viewers who are not familiar
with the french scene
yeah yeah and i've said it once saying
again i'm gonna say i'm like a broken
record but i'm so glad they've got to
show the world now on the takachi stage
how strong they are because
there's more than what you just see
about france
like you've said it before about there's
a tournament
watch one of them just one day just
treat yourself
get a hot
cup of cocoa
watch that tournament there's going to
be so many players that you aren't aware
of that are giving those top players
problems and with a merry other teams as
well yeah that's absolutely uh
ridiculous but while kasuga and vesprin
will sit comfortably in windows final
they will play first to three later look
at how freaking ridiculous this loser
side of the bracket is junior is about
to play hazel the winner of this play is
no car silver blade's about to play
chomp the winner of this place kane and
fun fact the current top three of europe
one is kane first with 145 silver blade
second with 105 and no car third with
80.
the top three of the leader broads are
all in losers right now c4
i don't know about all top dassa
i think the term
shark tank is running around a lot
that's actually
that's jaws tank
there's mad killers because they're
literally the top of the leaderboard
that's crazy
and to know that one of them sharks are
going to get killed the people in the
top are feeling happy about themselves
but if you're someone like janana go who
is one of my boys a 17 guy and a hazel
one of the tohan army veterans you're
gonna be scared so scared but you've got
a fight man you made it this far to top
eight
got to finish off the work
you got to finish the work indeed and
and the way this bracket is going right
now it completely opens up the scenarios
that could happen
from today absolutely ridiculous juna
lago versus hazel is the next match of
the day we are switching into the losers
bracket which means now we are playing
for the tournament life
oh man and these two players
they
i mean both of the teams right you can
see the team this is the epitome without
having teen on your team this is the
pity of one touch just one touch in your
whole squad it's on base coup a show
that's been very popular over at eu we
had loads of players not even just in
france playing this team yeah crazy
damage and we all know what fujio does
he you with a mid and your life
disintegrates right and he's got 17
behind it
yeah absolutely that's uh one thing that
i want to see on this one this these
teams are both uh quite ridiculous tune
and ago uh finally getting back to his
name right like for a while he was not
playing android 17. and i was like why
are you playing why are you named junior
lago if you're not playing 17 bro that's
a mix
it hurt man there was there were several
dm's set between me and him
like change names fun
you don't deserve it
stop teasing me in brackets i've seen
you then i go and i'm not seeing android
17 at least play 18 at that point please
yes you've gone back to his roots
now that thing's like you know saying i
love goku blue and playing a team of
three goku but not goku blue
speaking of the guy the monster island
ranger is on the field chasing gt
heartland to hit
bryony
hazel with a down kamehameha and
ton of damage coming there is one assist
available if he wants to extend but he's
gonna need it he's 17.
he's doing it by himself man on his
islands
the one-man army man it must be done
and look at the aggression
that was sick but
drop the bubble
yeah we're not pressing buttons right
now the vanish card console is countered
by a vanish
wow no field of super dashboard he is
daredevil incarnate man
oh yep he's just going to a
save meter with this one and that is a
dead base goku and that's amazing
because in hazel's team the character
you should kill early is definitely base
goku
yeah i feel he's definitely the uh the
glue that keeps him together
in terms of uh damage yeah and the
blocks on his assist so yeah that's a
big deal though
number three
decides to go for a high low behind this
we'll go for no not
nothing the no mix mix
no key straight up yeah all kind of
reset with the grammy walking stuff
doesn't work it's gonna be neutral
though
you have to put man down and that's
going to be extended
tuna go ha
level 3
what do we got
oh my god you wanna bait something bait
this [ __ ] punch man up that was galaxy
the delay on the dp from hazel
my god too smart and he's going to lick
off this 17 health
that's like oh you thought
[Laughter]
too smart for you
no you can't do reckless you can't block
hold this dragon punch
that hurts
that's hurt let's see
it's a 2v2 now hazel still has like five
six seconds of spark remaining and he's
getting an opening but no gauge to
vanish this one six m and nothing
yeah good blocks by drew nanna go
how's that
okay
yes
go for this and that's going to be
vegito by himself with spark
which means
uh
it's long
it's going to be hard vegeta is
ridiculous by himself it's work but gets
the opening on hazel's side
yeah mr two hates the flash kick whiffed
but like you said right this is the d.o
with the spark
this is going to be a manual install
yeah he's dead he's dead
yeah
he's actually instilled
manual insta kills this is what this
character has been doing
he's not even gonna need the level three
this is the character vegeta is right
now
and you know now any hits on that gohan
is probable death
i don't know i would say guaranteed i
mean
let's find out let's find that he's
still got spark but it depends where he
hits him right i think he's all right
yeah he's dead i called it yeah don't
forget but he's got level 4 in it that's
true but how much can we get with this
can you extend this nah he's not there
it's not his name he's like he's alive
c4 united
i thought
i thought we could get a 501 oh no
let me stop the dragon rush
no
what is happening
the precious game's gonna play as i flew
damascus oh my gosh
oh my god oh
my god the dragon rush will spark save
him
yes it will one touchy
[Music]
don't look at me i'm scared bro
i'm scared i'm blocking for my life i
can't believe you woke up like that
yo you know what no no no no i don't
want to hear anything i respect the hell
out of this dp
because it's simple you you are okay
let's let's let's be honest c4 right
like the two opponents are looking at
each other in the corner
right
the next hit
is part of a guess because if both of us
press a button
at almost the same time whoever pressed
it to frame before wins right so why
don't you inflict that guess on your
opponent by doing the dp instead
this is why i'm a good player i can't
think that far down the the the rabbit
hole man
i'm just going to get the art again hold
that i'm just going to hold the mid
and get dragon rough again i'm not up to
that level
uh
should you go wrong he was ready you're
ready
all right i wonder if level one was
killing though because the spark was
still there
and you know it seemed level one i don't
know yeah
yeah it's a bit hard to calculate
sometimes with beans because they
obviously do damage over time they're
not like tm where it's just one grit of
health being taken away yeah it's it's
really really difficult with this but
hazel with a very very strong start
there immediately eliminates that
android 17 and june ago has the two
fusions to work with what okay
wow man shots up in his face nearly got
the confirm of the fire though elbows
avoided up being whipped super dash
never does though when all when in doubt
super dash out get the hit get the knock
down and start
impression
where you going
right with blocks and the two h on this
one
big boy damage coming up as well
depending on how much she exactly wants
to do
yeah put him in the corner
oh we're gonna give him
we'll go g a level three
oh yeah we spark this time he wants to
save that base goku
facebook who died early
oh no on the happy birthday did not
happen thankfully gt goku is small
yeah yeah yeah
he got his future self and his younger
self the the younger self escaped but
basically the original is going to go
down do you know bringing it back and
with his sparks still intact he's got a
pretty good lead right now
kind of fortunate we're just a few days
too late for the national uh throw a
short person away day
that gta goku would have been bodied man
the yitz were legal three days ago
now we're back to about the original
game in season two ratatouille
right that cooks people and look right
now dragon rush gets tanked good stuff
flash this whiffs
all right cool can i escape the corner
as well smart movement by chilling i go
and hazel's gonna put the pressure on
mixed
no combos though
i time
literally
not much damage though but
it's all about the knockdown right
oh good luck could take as well the
defense is solid
oh my gosh
vanishes has to block the bombos
i think that's the opening but that was
a 2l don't get a ton of bars so not
going to be able to kill just decides to
go for the soft knock down no conversion
of that assist but he's getting the
super dash regardless
yeah nice and close unreactable by mrs
the jump s go for another one bp no two
page the pressure's definitely getting
to the players right now
oh no
hazel is being is getting hit by a ton
of super dashes right now he would
definitely benefit from slowing down a
little bit and potentially you know
going forward
yeah i definitely feel he's getting hit
by the supernatural because he's trying
to space himself but ginago is just so
aggressive look at this look what he's
doing
oh he tried nope nope nope not happening
just yet
oh no he got both
he got both
he could not kill super saiyan 4 vegeta
without happy birthday there
i would expect the hell out of that of
course he had sparked make it safe
fix my face
all right hazel you need to block for
your life right now
that's a risky vanish as well there
because a counter vanish would have won
you know with this
just like this
overheads
straight to your face
should i go
he's gonna move
over hazel go down
i i was such a ruling battle because if
anyone's seen those two players before
ginogue is very very aggressive and he
will take liberties if you give him an
inch definitely take them all right and
the way that hazel plays is very neutral
heavy
uh but it's hard because he's his
assists kind of benefit him going in he
likes to wait for his moment and janana
go just did not give him a chance so we
are going to see him going through and
he's going to go up against noka in the
quarterfinals
in a little bit
right now
damascus this is the game i've kind of
been looking forward to the most
silver blades versus
machop first off i want to ask the chat
how many of you guys are familiar with
chope
like like a silver blades i know a lot
of you guys know simba blades one of the
best knappers in the world absolutely
ridiculous uh excellent player he was
sent to losers by vesprim by the way
trump
is
chomp is like
one of the biggest brains i've witnessed
on dragon ball fighters i think i think
that's a good way to put it
chomps
brain
levels are
immense to say the least he
man
he's had such a like varied path through
through dragon ball because i knew trump
when he was the ssa vegeta player and
me and him both played ssj on point so i
thought man's culture didn't it
then i see him playing all the pig flow
stuff i've been he's playing 16 with a
asus and he is doing the grimier stuff
uh i've seen him been i think the last
time i saw him he was playing like
piccolo 16 zebraly he was not messing
about man's trying to get points i
respect him yeah
all right let's see what he brings today
and obviously like you said silver
blades everyone kind of knows silver
blades now it's napa plus two 21 beerus
normally right that's normally i must
say i'm seeing i'm seeing the plus 2
right now c4 and god damn win for a
treatment silver blades always brings
the the most interesting kind of
chemistry and characters around there uh
of course champion he said it like he
changed teams a lot i've seen him lately
with like a big boy team like a zebraly
super brilliant 116 he got two out of
these three today and silver blades of
course it's always napa he's always one
of the the
mix you know the master mixers in this
game and look at this he is playing
guinea
and
android 16 what a team
i no spoilers no spoilers i i've seen
stuff from getting you giving you that
but i used to play a tiny bit labs some
stuff before i'm not good enough to pull
this off but silver blade is not me he's
a far better human figure than me he
will be able to pull off the darkest
stuff
you know like the guinea stuff with the
left right imagine that with an
apparatus when you can't see because of
the visas yeah
yeah exactly this all right let's see we
open
against a pointer z broly what do we got
silver blades putting him straight into
the corner let's see what we're gonna
get from that guinea that is a very very
interesting theme for super blades right
now
gets the vanish anyway
let's see
yeah he is absolutely out there he won't
even need to do the
stuff but he does go for it
sparks trump wanting to keep his main
guy alive
this is like bad crashes
yes it's only gonna get worse
oh my god everything is downstream bro
this is this is visual pollution i
actually don't know what's going on are
they playing with uh with unlimited
assist on
oh no okay guard cancel to get away that
broly is still alive
and uh trying to get something with that
hundred day team chomp right now looking
for something without relating the super
dash full screen got to watch out the
second part of that assist is gonna clip
that's ginyu and now it's time for napa
i'm so glad i'm here to commentate a
match with two people using
168 assists
season one man
it's absolutely insane sorry yes it's
season one it's back to season one see
sixteen anchor
uh out there oh no he drops that dragon
rush there and the barrier is gonna stop
him from getting in the five eight good
one chomp he's got a sister extent
uses one probably won't need to use both
even for the oh he does go for it okay
yeah that's okay i've got damage anyway
yep and you know what the left right is
gonna be just too strong and it's gonna
get killed you can land the hit but
there is a sparkle silver blade side
doesn't need it brings in the toaster
decides which sheet yeah
i have no idea he needs some half
let's go for this we're going to extend
just putting him down yep dragon rush
probably gonna call here
the invisible mix and great conversion
by trump got to watch out because the
sister coming back right now
i don't think he can build enough anyway
so he's just gonna use the bar again for
the extra mix and straight to the spark
and here we go the toaster going in the
last of the mohicans good block on the
low
mix
stop stop stop stop stop next
unreasonable mixes oh but we haven't got
the combo shut up ah
imagine thinking your barrier's gonna
stop me from grabbing you
what do you think this is usually oh
it's time it's one player more time
that's it that's it that's it that's it
when napa when you're in the corner
against nappa with cyberman it's not the
two-player game anymore
it's silverblade's playing story mode
yeah yeah
yeah john was spectating he just didn't
know it
he became a spectator he just wasn't
aware of it at the time might unplug his
pad it'd be like that what
16 full health like you said it might be
the throwback don't call it a comeback
oh i can't step on these laces he tried
we tried watch out
that in football that's a foul
why has somebody got a literally a 12 12
member squad
he's got too many cabs on his team how
is this allowed
finished
silver blades taking game number one
silver blade is actually playing more
npc characters than point characters
he's got all the guinea squad and simon
like clearly the best character in the
game because you can't do nothing about
him when he's out
this team is not it's not balanced
at all
he's playing a 4-3-3 what's he doing
all right let's oh my god trump is angry
he's good wait that's a happy birthday
ah he did not convert to the happy
birthday i think he could have
probably killed yeah
thank you
layers
let no jump
man here with the national express from
the railway trains but napa comes in
you're planning oh shut up man i'm fresh
out of the gym
i've got moisture you're riding this
train regardless
we got
really needs you to be pointless to get
anything
allow the barrier to build some meter
watch out oh
i think she's dead
yeah
money two bars would she
oh yeah he's not really the boss not
forget the password he's the other one
good patience from silver blades gonna
wait on this one blocking blocking again
yeah
five m's alone my guy gotta remember
nice re-jumps oh
yeah cool
you're only gonna get optimal when it
comes to saw blade snapper
sixteen on deck
and silver blades get a solid lead still
got spark as well
reflects chichi train doesn't reach he
didn't get to the station bro
that's definitely nothing on the ground
feels bad but the toaster in full effect
try to reach up and grab him
this whoa
chaos
chaos that's what it is and that's going
to be a dead z
broly silver blades he's gonna put napa
in
and now it's a napa versus android 16
chomp on his final character
yeah
it's doable man we've seen it many times
in the past
he's got the bar to make it work what
has he got the neutral
what there's so much
single player mode c4
he's playing arcade mode right now
this is the most obnoxious combo oh my
gosh let me see if that's something
again
not for me man
none of these giggle combos get out of
it said that and you know the worst
thing i've just realized at the end
silver blades napa looks like one of the
guinea foot members with the purple
that's why you look so mad but
but jump
said no more games all right you got me
silver blades go full
fight your rival kane uh but shout outs
to the chump
a very quick one right this is most
likely not a rage quits if you guys did
not know there is a delay when you're
spectating the match on dragon ball the
delay is somewhere around five to ten
seconds like compared to real life
matches so sometimes what happens is the
ko screen is done
he was pressing button and just
after like after the ko and i will lose
connection before because i'm delayed so
it's most likely him just leaving after
the ko regardless we like it for
you know just yeah just for good measure
but look at this top six now the castle
gave us the stream in windows final and
then on the loser side noka versus june
and ago and honestly c4 i thought that
would be grand finals skating against
silver blades i expected this to be
grand finals today
you're not alone you're not alone in
that thought process at all i i
definitely could have seen that uh as
probably the highest possibility and
then maybe castle got or no car sneaking
in there but uh yeah we're getting that
losers quarter finals and again we have
to stress about what you said about the
scores right
this is a big deal for both of those two
players
it it is it is huge so obviously nokai
is currently third on the leaderboards
kane first silverblade second right and
all of them
are losers right now
and it's it's definitely
looking like a an extremely difficult
run for all of them at the moment no car
accident i go and after that we've got
kane with the silver blades and
basically i think whoever defeats
like the other one and goes on to
like grand finals if kane wins or if
silver blaze wins and then goes on to go
in finals the other one is completely
out of the race right it's done
so um it's it's kind of a grand finals
for their chances to qualify to the
regional fighters because remember only
one person qualifies in europe one
and
you you've seen the the pool of thailand
there is right now it sounds harsh but
it'd be like that
tournament man
that's that's that's what sure
tournaments be like you gotta kill your
fellow friend of the countrymen and only
one person who can say they're the best
of the or the winner and that's what's
gonna happen here and yeah it's gonna be
the way that it's shaped up now i have
no idea where to call it no idea because
the two players that we thought weren't
gonna make it uh in winner side made it
so they
they've brought their a game uh but now
it goes into first of three right from
finals uh not yet
it's the last last four will be first
two three yeah so we have two more for
us to choose and then we swap into first
to three uh the players are in the lobby
we are on losers bracket right now uh it
is going to be the losers quarter finals
noka
taking on
june ago let us see
which one of these two will move forward
into top four into first to three
territory as well that's where you want
to be right you want to be illustration
where uh you will get a bit more matches
to adapt to your opponents to get used
to him players are ready
noka
vs
the first tattoo to stay alive in the
tournament
this is gonna be an insane match because
both of these players are super
aggressive
super super aggressive they they love
six they love to go forward they love to
oppress their opponent so i'm really
looking forward to this match
as you said the pressing start
as you said oppressive start man let's
go for this one
can i say full screen could reflect but
you still lock down and we get the
opening
yep can you be with us that was really
interesting then yeah we're not going to
take the escalator
take them stairs gets the knock down and
pins them down again and this is going
to be
yeah this is what the game's going to be
it's going to be mixed pression
pressure mixed oppression pressure
one third oh that's painted oh my god
that should be enough to kill and that's
you kill one and a half character right
you kill vegito and you kill spark
yeah
two for one bug off
buy one get one free spinning two bars
will be enough that's your take for go
just get your membership card man
get the extra rebates that you can get
nuka looking very solid for a star
junior going down to two characters and
that vegito was doing so much damage in
the earlier match it's definitely a
strong one to take it out as soon as
possible
yeah you know even if you're not from
the eu you know that assist does wonders
for but you're neutral and your team
comp
losing that it's gonna be a bit of an
issue you know semi enan
gr doesn't have the greatest synergy but
it does have pressure and i mean that's
where juno nego shines
what is happening
yeah
that was hard
that was bad
he got bamboozled that was called call
krillin man he's he's the he's the
acting police
let him come with his semi-flying car
and then and arrest the man
[Laughter]
yeah that that was not legal that was
not that all combo is actually crazy
every time i see it's doing some madness
all right down to super saiyan 4 gogeta
but the opening
goes
to loka putting the pressure on he's
gonna put his opponent in probably a
one-touch situation
yeah brings him down to the ground
spends the bar no that just goes
positioning okay
nice movements
and slippery
how's it gonna get this one yeah you
don't
that's
that's a vintage mix yeah it resists
yeah village
all right send them down
will take an extremely convincing game
number one right now
making the statement showing like you
know what
i got blessed with the side of the
loser's bracket without silver baits and
k in i'm using it
100 100 that's got to be going for their
mind right now and uh yeah stuff like
that you know guest reflex it's
something that you see a lot of people
do against people like michael and
janana go because they're so aggressive
you think that they're not thinking what
they're doing you you think they're just
running the script on you
but they are calculating when to press
buttons they're just so quick with it it
seems that they're just doing it so uh
you're going to see down both sides i
feel uh it's just that ginago needs to
get the party started and like you said
i think lucifer jio was the linchpin in
the
success of noka there i think that made
it's so much easier to go i could just
run forward now you haven't got like
an assist to stop me from approaching
absolutely let's see uh if you can keep
this one going junior is taking some
time in
the lobby maybe potentially changing
teams i mean he's got a few other teams
as well as i've seen him like rotating
teams or maybe just taking a breather
because of course right now one more
loss for joe and i go would mean that
he's out of the tournament at fifth
place decides to stick with the same
team loca one tuna
zero let's see if drew and i go
can put some pressure on noka because
that was really noka favorites
yeah uh i think one strategy that kind
of favors jonatha's team a little bit
more is going for the levels i mean it
sometimes seems a bit trolly and it's
going to be very hard to do against no
car it might be a trump card in his
arsenal if you decide to go for it
absolutely okay let's get them laid down
and immediately the opening from kid
would you not go maybe a bit uh
scared on that defensive side against
kid i mean who is it
we we all show fear in the face of ube
100 here we go five h guard council this
time keeping all three members alive for
the time being
okay okay okay we still got more nope
and that is going to be extension after
extension nokia's kid who is putting a
ton of pressure
staircase good reflection are you
why are you reflecting i've got an
extendable leg
he's been reflective from day like
good actually just ignores that mechanic
he's all accomplished all combos and his
m's ignore the reflect mechanic just
straight
yeah
all right
back to full screen
i'm gonna be forced to block that kid
bro has been an absolute problem for
julian lego he would definitely gain a
lot in putting him under pressure but no
car again
damn
here we go not going to get the three
bars but he's just going to get the same
situation right junogo is taken upwards
and he's catching every time with the
jump lights
surprise
surprise
let's extend this one
and level three
yeah he wants he wants to just get the
guaranteed knock down at least and put
some pressure on that kid we don't get a
lot at this range great back dash but
the patience of draenor goes correct
good blocks again still blocking
movements
his name after him and he's got a ton of
work to do right now definitely a
character who can be super annoying by
himself
let's see the soft down he's there mixed
that's the mids
straight up you know what the thing is
with our spark i wouldn't think this is
doable but the fact that he has sparked
he can build the bar that he needs to
make something work solo it's gonna be
hard it's not easy right now it's not
looking doable as nokia does get the hit
he's got six bars but he dropped the
combo
all right with blocking good luck no
that would have been dead if here if
noka committed to that buttons andrea is
just looking for way out right no no no
no no no why are you flexing from
yes stop wagging your finger in front of
me bro that's that's not what we do here
nice gets the bar
punch
boxer man and he's still holding on to
his spot i was saving for too long
[Music]
all right we take those we take those
that's trouble right now he might need
to spark to extend and he does not spark
that's an absolute win for june i go
because no canal is
only on spark level 2
that was the most perfect situation for
janana still the spark i feel you have a
spark in youtube though because you are
going to die now
i was just about to say you can't
survive
a
auis free spark combo
you needed this [ __ ] neutral
yep that is unfortunate that level 3
should be enough no car
about to take
that second point that is too nil
for loka he's moving forward
to that loser semi-final
a convincing two-nil unfortunately for
june ago
for probably like a bit of a difficult
resource management there but that is
going to be juneau go out at fifth
and no castillo alive in the tournament
yeah i think that's where it was right i
mean obviously i just blurted out last
minute like you should have just sparked
a neutral but it's not that easy you can
get sniped especially with ui because
you are super quick and he's got
tracking uh supers yeah so he might have
been able to react to it so you can't
just spark in neutral yet uh maybe
sparks on the gojira combo to go well at
least i'm gonna have some regen if i get
hit next round but that's something that
janet goes gonna have to take to
laughing for next time as nokia does get
another w on the boards uh sorry his
first w because he did lose the response
because he wasn't winning side yep so he
is going to be waiting
for the arrival of kane or silver blades
for semi-finals
who knows who knows who's going to see
an open semi-finals the masters i can't
call it chat can you i'mma be honest i
don't know man i don't know
we have mentioned this earlier today
guys
i believe this would be the grand finals
for today
these two guys
are currently first and second in the
leaderboards
came with 145 points
and silver blades with 100 points
both players
are working extremely hard
in
grinding to get a chance to uh be at
this vision finals but
at the moment
because of the way points work right
let's take a look uh at the point
because of the way points work
the loser of this
will only get 45 points
the winner of this
unless he's topped by noka
will get an advance that should
eliminate the other one from the race to
qualifiers uh even with the tenkaichi
online events uh that are remaining at
the moment but of course kasuga and this
game are currently in those brackets
nokai is third right now he's right
behind zero base at 80 points so
the qualifier spot is ex super super up
for grabs right now if you guys have not
seen who was invited in france uh in in
europe sorry because it's the european
finals at france it is kaiden wawa yasha
jila wade shanks gropius and mr popo
these are the eight inviteds and as for
the tank it online challenges uh in the
uk region plug is comfortably first i
think plug will be the qualified one in
the europe for germany uh region panda
is comfortably first but zarc is right
behind him so it could still
change and in spain there is still the
master event next week
for spain that will decide of uh who
spain is sending us it should be between
miami and uh chaokas who are currently
first and second
in the spanish event obi assassin was
invited but unfortunately he cannot do
these dates uh so he will have to
i mean i still feel sad about this but
yeah but he has to i mean he feels bad
about this too but yeah he has to uh
step back there are no more tournaments
for eu4
people can still run tournaments that's
what i'm saying you can run tournaments
until 14th of november
14th of november
is the end of the online qualifier
season uh so that is what we want we are
waiting for the players to join c4 kane
silver blades who who
who do you think will take this one
it depends on what team game plays i'm
i want kane to bring the brutality i
wanted to bring the s broly i wanted to
bring the best brody team because when
he brings the esprit team i get mad
acting i'm all active frames i'm all
active fans i'm moving mad quick but
angry though that's my face if if he
doesn't pick xboy that's gonna be my
face but uh yeah i think s broly brings
something to
the game
that people aren't ready for um i know a
lot of people think he's not very good
blah blah blah but kane played s broly
back in the day yeah and just kind of
stopped and i think it was just to keep
up with all the other players in france
right yeah we're not going to see it
today unfortunately
i begin you stuff from silver blade side
it's just a madness it's baffling i am
literally confused
ah let's see what this one's gonna say
chat press one for kane
press two for silver blades who are you
rooting for on this
losers quarterfinals one of these you
will be out of the tournament and
potentially out of the hope to qualify
to the offline regional finals let's see
civil plays bringing the early hits
i i i just don't know man this is so
worth it
yeah deleted
that's actually a sparkler cody by the
way you can actually sparkle stud off to
end of 2m with like two bars on the
right
team and that is an extremely strong
start by silverblade right now kane
super saiyan 4 vegeta out
brown bread and i'm telling you this is
the thing
it's going to be really hard to to fight
this onslaught that silverblade brings
with his team and we've seen it a couple
of times with people like history plays
in gamba playing ginyu
but with napa
that's a definitely an a pair that we've
rarely seen before kane putting that
napa down and now trying to get another
opening silver blade is blocking so
we'll go straight to the spark right now
vanish to create the cyberman sandwich
we're blocking by now straight to one
straight to spark straight to sport more
pressure the success
i just realized
again super blake's using ub
yeah
he likes he likes the team he likes the
squads
energy
oh speaking of nice confirm level one
into level three good stuff meter
burning
get as much damage as possible while the
spot's still alive and no kill
exactly what he needed to but okay
come back come back go back i'm not
gonna let him go just yet
reflect stay full screen
it's going to be
a mixed situation
put her into the corner
just super dash bro
that was the mix the mint
what
not the stream cut the stream too much
too much
everyone's a victim against snapper
everyone's a victim
victim indeed
victim indeed excellent play by civil
blades right now and kane is staying
full screen with that genemba trying to
use the orb to lock him down and good
one he's going to be able to set up the
50-50 with the level 3 right now
all right 50-50 left or right where does
he go c4
you're blocked see the place did not and
he is going to exercise but he can to
override
the meter nerf and he will that is a
dead ginyu and now it's much more
durable for general
it is it is for sure because napa like
you can see sliver of health but don't
forget he can plant an st character into
the ground oh nice he's not gonna that
was movement and now it's a 1v1
keynes chenemba versus silver blades
android 16.
for the amount of time syllables on the
lead in this match it's surprising that
it's so 50 50 at the end
yeah that's actually really true and
this is a matchup i don't think i've
ever seen on 1v1
big reaching i played geneva and i don't
think i've ever had this one
oh no but watch out got to watch out
could reflect
yeah i'm
not spanish i think you might want to be
careful full screen
so what he needs to worry about right
yeah
oh he's not going to pick up on this one
kane looking for a bit more right now
this movement got to watch out still
blocking it's a one touch on both sides
kane is not blocking and that's going to
be the vanish not going to kill just yet
no he's going to get a lot of bar and
he's going to get the corner position
two and a half good job
[Music]
oh that was risky as hell
i got a command grab two yeets that man
out of there and silver blades saves the
match it is one nil
for silver blades
the goddamn
that was hard as hell
man said
you call that a knife
this is the knife scooped him robby he
ran up to it and grabbed him while the
good old days
it's very interesting let's go uh we
need to see kane obviously bring it back
but also we need to see that gujita for
kane because civil blades eliminated the
gojita so early earlier this is what
kane did with only two characters and
look at this another opening
this
captain is so big brain you can see his
brain outside of his skull you need to
understand this character is only for
the biggest the brains
yeah you can't spot that nev it's never
been there where's the astronaut meme
this guy is actually dancing on him bro
he's strictly come dancing
call the rest
call on adults
he's spinning
silverblade's never changed my guide
never changed
that kojita has absolutely not been a
factor at all c4 and at least he manages
to kick that cyberman out
when he gets the
extremely good starter right now second
hit of the auto combo big damage because
very low scaling
yeah this is crazy damage good
good way to delay his buttons but
man this game assist is working out what
we don't make mistakes yeah happy
accidents
oh let's go get the extension there
silver blades is gonna be able to get an
extension
yes nice one
cyberline is there okay he's blocking
nice one got to watch out because simon
is coming kane you can't really escape
and
c4 it is down to genumba
no spot for kane
kane playing his entire life
we might not see kane offline in
december
and this is what he has to fight up
against what a squad there is no way
you've laughed against it no one has
this is crazy and it's working out he
gets he gets given the subway but he
doesn't like gherkins he gave it back
he's getting out of the bad situation
but he's in the corner damascus where's
he gonna go from here though
we're blocking all right
so one of the good things about jennifer
versus napa is that genema now has a one
of a frame one counter and that can
actually
counter the cyberman gap
whenever simon goes for this but you
know what
silverblade's got the one but he did not
go for the right combo on this one
that's unfortunate still gonna get the
opening kane not blocking the overhead
and silver blades
he's going to be the winner
of this match
dominant
dominant
two nil when do you see kane
so helpless
when do you see someone have to block
getting you in nappa that's that's the
only answer i can give you man like i
saw silver blades tweet out a guinea
gift a couple of weeks ago and i was
like it's probably like a teemo thing
he's going to stick with the the beerus
stuff right the the tried and true but
yeah this team is is tmoc he's actually
just toxic and he's got the right colors
for as well there's all purple all the
time
there's too much going on too much going
on
got speed to no car that's all i gotta
say you're gonna have to rush him down
so much that he can't call a system what
not but um
yeah that is gonna be our semi-finals no
car
open and uh burning heads silver blade
in semi finals
this
has been an extremely intense one
casual in this premiumness final no
concealer blades on the right right now
i mean regardless is going to be
difficult right but
considering
considering the current
leaderboards right so at the moment kane
is first with 145 silver blade second
with 105
right noka third with 80
and then kasuga it only has 37 vesprin
only has 15 right so
what kane needs right now
he needs no car to beat silver blades
and then to lose in loses final
right
if
this happens
this will give the final 200 points to
someone who's who will not be far
above kane and potentially give him a
chance
so mathematically speaking it's still
doable but that will rely on first noka
getting this and silver blades needs to
be
prevented from reaching grand finals
because if he reaches grand finals
the 105 points he has right now
will be at least 255 which is more than
100 points over kane and that's the gap
that's gonna be really hard because
these two are always in grand finals
of the tournaments right so
mathematically speaking
it's like doable for absolutely everyone
it's quite possibly the most open
the most open situation we uh
we could get so let's
see how this one goes because right now
right kane
being fifth means he's 190
points right which is timothy
and remember because kasuga only has 37
if kasuka wins he's only 40 points ahead
of kane
so
he takes an option but it's not gonna be
done until the end
that's the one it's extremely extremely
close for today and that's that's the
best scenario man
yeah yeah because this just makes the
storyline go even longer until you said
uh sometime in december because they're
going to have to play the online series
they're going to have to go to the
locals and get points that way because
they can't just go oh i got
second the first in the tenkachi the
masters don't worry about it no one else
is catching up to me they will catch up
so you're gonna have to keep playing
even if you get that high lead right and
like you said right now kane is
he is looking at horoscopes but he needs
so many stars to align so he can stay
near the top
uh he's obviously clearly hoping that
noka can do what he couldn't and stop
silver blades but the way he is moving
the way all of them moving he's got like
10 people in his team i don't know how
you stop that yeah the only thing i can
think of is nova has to go in with the
ube the in with the ui and not give him
a chance to do so yeah exactly there are
a ton of scenarios but we're not casual
just dm me ask me can i still qualify
i'll let you know kasuga
so guys we are at top four right now
which means it's going to be a first two
three all around right now every single
game is going to be first to three
kasuga versus this premium winners final
noka versus silver blades in on the
loser side
of the bracket only one winner to take
these 200 points in one of the closest
races we could get so guys what we're
gonna do is we're gonna take like a
quick break like less than 10 minutes
eight minutes say eight minutes we're
gonna take an eight minutes break right
now i'm gonna refill this because i'm
almost out of water and i don't wanna
die today because this match is
absolutely ridiculous let's get a quick
break and then we'll be back with the
winners final kasuga versus vesprim and
then of course on the other side noka
versus steeler blades guys get a drink
get a snack back in eight
with the top four of that master event
who will qualify for the europe one
region don't miss the hype be back in it
guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
what is goods
ladies and workers boys and boomers we
are back
arena two europe one
master series we have gone from top
eight to top four now first the freeze
france has taken over this tournament
and man
if you've missed the first games
obviously later go back and watch the
archives but now it's just gonna get
absolutely
nail-biting
when it comes to the points
this is the breakdown again give us the
breakdown in terms of pure viewing
experience might be the the most
entertaining bracket we could get
uh mainly because the rundown is
currently
the top four in order
uh for this region
is uh
is kane with 145 points then silver
blades with uh 105 points then noka with
80 and then kasuga with 37 right so
these are the top four of this kane just
took fifth place so kane is only going
to take 45 points uh on
uh on developers right now right so
there are still a mix of 70 100 150 200.
now it's pretty simple
silver blaze wins the entire tournament
it's going to be
borderline impossible take him down
unless unless he gets absolutely bodied
on the next few tournaments that reza
runs and you know he gets like keep kept
away from top eight and stuff which you
know is extremely hard uh it's it's
going to be a strong option but aside
from silverblade's win
any single win from other players
wouldn't mean a guaranteed qualification
because if kasuga wins the tournament
you will get 237 points there will only
be 47 points ahead of kane so it will
take two tournaments of kane placing
better and casual and canes in france
you know if noka wins solid option as
well not impossible depending on where
silver blades end up you know and if
this premium same because this cream is
pretty low in points right now uh that
still something else can be taken over
so the the status of the european
ranking is still very very open and
it is probably not going to be closed by
the end of the day today and that is
what we want because there are still
tournaments the tenkaichi online season
runs until mid-november everyone can run
tournaments on every uh you know
available region but for now we are
going to move towards winners final
we are entering
first to three
situations right now every single game
is the first to three and our winners
final is going to be the following
kasuga
versus vespirim kasuga who sent kane
into losers the stream who sent noka
into losers one of them
will
guarantee a minimum of 150 points if he
joins grand finals who will be there
casual obviously
this is yeah this is going to be such an
insane fight first degree like you said
perfect tune as well evil 21 one of the
best springs don't have me telling you
it is after west city but it's still up
there but it probably
intensifies the hype and the importance
of this match okay let's go barrier
gets the first opening that's going to
be the one that this team will need to
be very mindful of casual is a master at
the barrier usage right now putting the
spring into the corner and the all the
tracking goal is double you know what we
don't care super dash
yeah none of that oh wait it's not a
beam call i'm just going to super dash
it fire you can stay here not much
damage though but look at this chris
brown wall-to-wall never mind he's never
gonna take the call and he's gonna go
for level three send him back to
mid-screen
no it doesn't have a bar for the vanish
but this is ui right he loves his mids
anyway so let's see the pressure yeah
just wants a bit
of pressure on this one he's waiting for
the assist to come back good reflect by
casual but you're gonna get caught by
this one not gonna kill just yet but
they scream taking some momentum
oh my gosh noggin
exposed
characters graham bread 21 down for
castlegar leaving two of the angels left
18 careful up you've seen casper can
make the comeback he's gonna have to get
some momentum started because this is a
try hard team from restaurants yeah and
not just available for this one right
now he needs to remember that the
monologue was happening on seventeen
side casual with the guard console he's
gonna be flying and gets caught by the
in the recovery frames this plane is
playing amazing right now
i wonder if we're gonna spend bar and
vet inside knows he's gonna
push to the corner but
that's the guy doesn't want to be put in
the corner jumps out goes over the
barrier the two hate working wonders for
restaurant gets the hit on the kefla
beating up the fusion
brings in kid bizzle
crap
and instead
this game is playing ridiculously
efficient right now against kasuga every
single touch is big boy damage into
pressure that is a dead kefla kasuga is
down to android 18 by yourself
this is a mountain and a half frame for
climbing it's doable like you said spark
on deck there's quite a bit of media to
work with as well nice gonna need the
resources and got the brother in the
back
power family not gonna work today
unfortunately windy punch
not now at all oh no the drop is gonna
be there because guys a chance right now
oop and he's gonna be forced to block as
well good block by casual the vanishes
that what
okay
gonna get quite a lot of meat for this
so he's building the meter he's got both
assists but no history is gonna stop him
of course not sure about that early
spark and yeah kasuga is going to spark
as well
trying to at least keep a chance right
now he needs to eliminate that dragoo as
soon as possible gets out
by the 5s here we go reset
i thought you might go for a cheeky
reset not happening just yet i told you
that i go oh
ignore it i don't care about your
brother
you know then once the matches when
someone sneezes twice he apologies
wasn't ready for the second one
my god like you say bless you and you
haven't even finished bless you the
second sneeze comes out exactly
all right then kid who is gonna
wrap a game number one an extremely
dominant one by the stream there and i
know that a lot of you guys watching
today
don't know about basically but this is
who he is he's been one of the silent
killers in france for a while and right
now
he's taking the first game over casual
of course
this is the first three
so there's more time for him to adapt
he's got some games casper's got some
games to get some tissue man get the uh
get the kleenex because man's got hay
fever that wake up man mad hate fever
if you're right oh
the early side switch there was
absolutely perfect
by the stream there
going to put
kasuga down
and the keyboard pressure is on kasuga
blocking good block on the mix right now
the six seven is not gonna be blocked
but you can't get much
wow just super dash doesn't want any of
that key blast pressure wow do you see
how he adapted that come over to the
delay that was super clean that is
kepler mastery at his finest but now
we've got 18 with the forehead
brother in the background spitting bars
[Music]
down bounds damascus
let's go
keep with the pressure yep level three
[Applause]
from z broly
counting
the knockdown on this
wow
man went for the frame kill
oh double reflect oh no yeah
kid was stopping you
and extension from that zebra you're not
gonna be able to get more and the tag
anyway catch his best friend sleeping
and that's going to be kefla
oh yeah dark has his both characters as
well
oh reflect wasn't needed the banish
but the two hey best room keys and cues
all checked
what is happening
that is a dead kefla what a nun so by
this game won't be boss either damn
that
it's very hard to give props to the ui
that was sick though that was actually
really sick
oh my gosh meat meat and you're dead
the best queen is running an absolute
train on this and you know
who must be happy about this cane
okay it wants the spring to get points
man he's like get points man gets point
i still i still want to stay there but
casual guy is in extreme trouble right
now the guy the command grab sorry
getting the opening and he's going to at
least get some
offense available there but no spark on
casual side this is looking long for man
like you said no spark got a bit of meat
and we've got some crispy creams monster
doughnuts time for the left right
no
no
no
no no
[Music]
that is a bit bored by this one and then
brony's level three oh
i don't know c4 i don't know i'll say no
i'll say no okay okay
one frank two this time
[Music]
a touch of almost death
that's that's what it was
almost there
into into the surprise mix behind
because you were like okay i'm dead no
gorgeous little tackle there yellow card
in football but we enjoyable fighters we
don't care we don't have
yeah them 240 tackles there they're not
kobe stuff they're not kosher
all right let's go
put them right into the corner right now
oh 2m doesn't hit but the jump l does
connect
best friend absolutely on a tear up this
game this is crazy
that is a man who came on a mission
today he was like these guys don't know
who i am i'm about to make a name for
myself today
man's going to get them good
followers later on 100 percent
that was almost cursed
bro
he was a dj khaled and another one my
first ole nah nah this second one ain't
gonna keep pressing we keep moving
forward yeah
oh no the guy is gonna be blocking
and
big damage they're coming on that 10321
okay
someone down level three
[Applause]
you've seen the frame kill before was it
this time
it's literally a good look oh a nice one
the barrier absorbed one of the moves
from zebra and that uh worked absolutely
perfectly straight to kefla
yep yep barry are actually working for a
change nice to see it stopping the
monkey floor from dean brody like you
said damascus and now the level three
from casual got no bars on deck
he said stop this imitation what is this
fan surface of me i don't want to see it
i'm the original
[Music]
the face is not shown so it doesn't
count
you know it could it could be someone
else
but the happy birthday combo was not
taken correctly
taking long
it's looking extremely long
but speaking of long you know 21's got
those long normals if they could land a
tail can definitely turn it
the 2h whiffed then kasuga could not
pick this one up but he's getting his
own opening the region he's going to
build that third bar that should be a
dead kibbu and a good opportunity to tag
that android dating in as well level one
into level one casual guy still alive
i'm not psychic i'm just observing
falling down with the tail normals 21
has got that good good range you've got
to be careful all the time when she's on
screen right now she's in the back
and it's 18 adverts versus bully
i got a command grab two it's not as
good as yours
but it kinda works mix nope
no mix
yep
the outies we opt out we're not staying
here trust me we're moving
brings in ui or combo back to the corner
alright
absolutely wants to block this one
and i think he tried to reflect
i'm not telling you because he's
reflected this a lot earlier that's
going to be a dead end with 180 invest
him on his way one touch away
from a three nil
over casual
needs to put all of his energy into this
21 android 21 is definitely capable of
making this comeback but we've got to
get out of the pressure the mix
yes
what a statement
from the man who clearly
wasn't considered the favorite of these
brackets
but with this he's already in grand
finals securing minimum
150 points
long
i've got one thing to say for vesperan
if you don't know get to know
follow him or twelve clearly he is
someone not to be trustful with
absolutely
absolutely let's see we got uh the
bracket updates the stream three
kasuga nil kasuga will be in loses
bracket he will have to
face the
winner of noka versus
silver blades of course every single
match right now
is going to be a difficult one and
this rim has a great moment right now to
just chill a bit sit down be like yo i
got a ton of points
already oh and i am waiting to see who
will i get to challenge for 50
extra points on this but what a
performance from this primer c4
yeah yeah gotta be happy with yourself
for sure what's that guaranteed 150
points right get into grand finals
you've got to be happy and
stacked is not a term
we can use for this tournament it was
more than that it was just buildings
upon buildings the pressure of all the
top players you have to go through to
get this far and another person you said
that best friend did beat to get this
far was silver blades yeah that's the
person putting into losers so
he's pulled his weight he's beat the
plays he has to and now like you said
he's got the luxury of knowing that
they've got a minimum of triple digit
figures going into the rest of the
tenkaichi yep and once again right this
might be the ideal scenario for kane you
know the stream winning
is definitely the ideal scenario for him
keeping him
in the race for the final spot on this
one
and this game is absolutely in a
position right now because you said it
right every single person who's in lose
bracket lost to the screen he's the one
who put all three of these guys
down and he just has to do it one more
time in a longer set and he's got two
chances
damn
is that is that really like the
restaurant side graveyard is that what
that is it's like laura brackey it's the
vesper graveyard that's the budget the
body bags he left behind that that's
that's what's on this side
that's pretty much all it's literally
just body bag after body bag on this and
well let's see at the moment
this prim is definitely looking
extremely strong kasuga will be waiting
in loses final but we're moving to loser
semi-final
a first to three
between noka
and silverblade silverblades who just
eliminated kane
from the tournaments and right now an
important moment as
syllables losing will also make keynes
like you know business a ton so
we know who kane is cheering for but
this can definitely go either way
yeah very very aggressive playstyle from
loca and a very very impressive team
from silver blades who's going to get
the first hit i don't need to ask the
question because i can see right now
there's still blaze with the ginyu
welcome to pressure oppression
time to play tetris or not you can try
and avoid it but you're going to get hit
yeah you going in damascus all right
we're blocking again
he has been in the blender since the
start of this game we are 27 seconds in
and these have been 27 long seconds for
docker
longest
the longest and it starts again
he's just weighted up the same mixtape
over and over again
by my mixtape he said all right finally
luka gets a first opening and he's gonna
make it count he absolutely needs to get
that king away and you know what like
that team is actually so scary c4
because when i think about it
silverblade's got two characters who
apply an unlimited amount of mix
in this team usually when you play napa
players you know that when you get napa
out
you're back to playing dragon ball
fighters you're not playing i get mixed
fighters
but with silver blades you need to pick
two to kill two characters for that yeah
he's doubled down and i really like it
he's actually just doubled down he went
i need another napa character so i don't
have one
uh like crucial character for my team
you can get rid of napa i've still got
the guinea fools behind me i've got gang
gang i've got the power rangers to back
me up
all right let's see that napa is gonna
put him to the corner there's no assist
available so so he's not gonna be oh
okay blue combo we take them we take
them they do they make the same damage
stay hydrated mid mid-match i like it i
like it
oh no that is too early in this segment
i don't think it's going to save him
from this combo nice gun he's not all
right
mocha extending oh the cross-up is gonna
be
blocked silverblade's trying to channel
his spanish roots siva blade is actually
hard spanish by the way so you know he's
uh he's got the dna necessary for this
but it's not gonna happen at all that
napa should be dead and luka is looking
dominant
man's gene's got the uh
the certified tick he's allowed to do
this it didn't work though and now he's
gonna lose his wool saiyan leaving
guinea with half health he does have
spark and damascus one thing i don't
think we have even thought about so far
is
we could get a body swap
we could
and all three of these characters have
seen silver blade play them so he could
potentially uh
try and have some fun on this one oh my
goodness straight to this part on this
and let's see see the blades getting the
opening
does have gundog
no
he needs gold for the side for the
body swap so he needs another
cycle of toku sentai uh loka might not
give him a chance to do so
extending can he beat the sparkle
covering though
oh the lockdown double overhead gets
blocked
quadruple overheads
uh three and a half we'll give it that
head butt back in the corner you go
never ending story of pressure gets out
thank you to jace
saving you from the punish
gonna have to give him the milky cannon
i believe
[Music]
all right
one down two to go silver plate
with the herculean task
ahead
let's see if we can get some no
not just he was ready yeah
ah nuka is gonna be
a patient to beat on this one
realistically speaking
i'm not saying anything
yeah
maybe he doesn't know that's the low
right oh my gosh gang gang
oh we can get hit he needed that he's
swaying
you might have to go and find time in a
minute i'm not
good to get that vacuum out the
supernatural gonna work
another one and then he gets the opening
no car
clutches that game regardless silver
blades was extremely close from
like
one of the strongest combat we could
think of ginyu by himself low life as
well that was the guinea who was in a
one-touch situation from the get-go man
yeah yeah i
i'm gropious
definitely send some massive energy but
we said in the dm when it's cool you've
got this it's ginyu people don't know
nearly done it man that is crazy
what was that neutral or was this
routers exploding
it might be a yeah
this looks like both players are in a
group in agreement that the routers are
exploding for seconds
might need to uh
uh might need to double check with them
on uh
on on what's happening
uh let's see the players are there let
us uh wait to see uh what is happening
on this one gonna check with the staff
uh on this of course just to see uh
because yeah it's uh it's like
la it's
it was looking long
for a second we were switching to
powerpoint indeed uh noka is at one
over silverblades right now and
it was a strong start
off the game but silver blades like
almost hit him with an extremely strong
combat
so definitely a
like
huge potential for noka to not only win
and win points but also give kane a
great gift of
a friendship being like okay let's uh
let us let us do this
yeah he will give uh kay in a bit of
reprieve when it comes to
going forward when it comes to gaining
points like you said we've done the
maths
uh i believe it's kane with 145
uh silverblade's 105 and then next is no
car i can't remember many points got i
think it's 80 something 90 something
and then i believe it's kasigar yeah so
it's kind of back to front the person
who had the most points has gone out the
earliest yeah so
like like damascus is kept saying
it is all to play for for the for the
leaderboard and it's not just between
like a one and two it's between like the
top five
uh best room
the biggest spanner in the works for all
of these players thinking damn i i guess
yeah absolutely the
top two is only gonna go to one of these
top four players so far
absolutely that's uh that's the one we
got a ton of points on this november
guys that the the number one at the end
of the season so on on 14th of november
whoever is number one of the
leaderboards will be in paris on the
first weekend
of
december for the regional finals that
are offline
so we'll join the eight invited players
along with the other three qualified
players from europe for high stakes
offline games that i absolutely
cannot wait for but let's see noka
versus
silverblades is the match at hand right
now waiting for the players to rejoin as
the lobby has been recreated and
and we'll see
and we'll see how this goes
you need your energy let's uh put your
hands together put your hands up if
you've got those as well just
need the energy for the lobby please
hold out it's first of three like we've
been saying for the top four
i really want to see this match i i
that last game with almost having a gin
you come back something that
you don't get to see often and we're
seeing
noka's aggression being matched with two
characters that we don't see too off the
napper in the eu obviously a little bit
more common when ginyu was literally
just a spanish character for a long time
for a long long time they're the only uh
the only region that made it work right
with uh grocus and uh gamba
and it's really cool to see the synergy
between
you and nappa that's uh
it's it's scary and i know halloween's
around the corner someone can cosplay as
them two characters i'll give them all
the candy that's a scary combination
simple bud because you you will cosplay
as mix
why are you dressed that
i am mixed you know you know that's meme
of the of the person who's in the corner
of the party by himself it's like they
don't know i'm dressed as mix right now
this is like i don't get it
that's why they're staying away from me
they don't want none of this they don't
want none of it
[Music]
that needs to be one maybe this
halloween i'll find someone to go his
mix and i'll go with oaky or something
like that that'll be funny i got it you
guys make that me get i will retweet you
tag me you know
a man like dressed as nappa or whoever
he's on the corner and he's like he's
with his drink alone it's like they
don't know i mix
keep an eye for me keep an eye out for
me and everyone is like dressed as
whatever is like everyone is dressed as
quick game characters because that's
what everyone will use you know this
time anyway that isn't it
paper scissors yeah adjustments rock
paper scissors get some friends yeah
yeah come as rps they don't get it
they'll know though
yeah definitely let's see this lobby is
being recreated uh just checking on this
and hopefully you know
we'll get a a solid match on this it's
going to be noka
versus silver blades noka with the one
nil the early one nil we're gonna start
of course at one nil
and have some more fun remember guys
that there is still one more uh master
event next week it's gonna be sunday
next week and it's going to be the spain
one spain the
europe
i think it's three of spain three so
it's spain portugal and italy so you can
expect to see miyami kaurkas scarlett
keckneya
you know like all of the guys you know
from the three countries of course you
know that uh uh they're going to be
grinding on this one and you know like
you know it guys like there are plenty
of tournaments that are running reza is
usually the ones who are the one who
runs the french tournament but a couple
of other people run i'm thinking about
team somme who run one uh nick v ran one
as well of this and anyone can so like
these are all uh very very active on
this and i'm definitely looking forward
to see like some more tournaments we got
all of the regions
looking extremely extremely good and we
get a ton so next week we still have
dragon ball fighters on this channel and
then the channel will like sleep for a
month uh playing you know will all be no
neutral november so like do make sure
that you uh don't wait or block or
anything press buttons in november and
then in december it will be the finals
but back in there with no caps silver
blades it's time
yeah no november yet so we can play some
neutral i mean it's going to be going
past real quick with these two players
and the way their teams are constructed
nice pickup of the uis is clean stuff
man like ube is in the building
all right sorry
mix
okay we extend
we try to get a bit more that hitboy is
immediately putting the pressure into
the corner and oh my god that is
perfectly baited luca is on the roll
this is exactly what he needs what he
wanted
and what he's going to get a dead genie
and the spark
clean off the table
gonna have to spend
three bars but you know what 100 worth
it
no pass looking super strong the
comeback kid he's been gone for a minute
all right wait a minute
there's no assist for the schmickster
so
yep get cyberman sandwich situation but
you know what i will flip around great
answer by silver blades the flips were
actually smart to try and get away from
the sandwich situation but silver blades
was ready
yeah that was a visual noise right this
flips making him scared good back that
he returns the favor with the baseball
you cannot play next to someone who's
got kp for my guy that is just real yeah
we don't do that
we don't do that
let's see this
look up putting my corner the sixth
sense is gonna open him up and that's
why goku is absolutely unleashed right
now
is he building that fifth bar yes i
think that's enough c4
one
[Music]
it's a low level one let's see
i think that might be enough though
actually
dead
noise
[Music]
man brown bread got rid of that napa all
from the 6m
oh yes
kid through being the body block taking
it here
allowing gojia to get the punish
ssj for getting the toaster on the
ground we're not fixing it today we're
just going to get rid of it and buy a
new one
[Music]
[Music]
oh i can do it too that was not silver
blade man
that was i don't
that hurts me though that actually
yo is he nah he's not dead right okay
[Music]
oh my gosh the masters there's no way
right we almost always give you but this
is ridiculous he's hanging on
over here jl thank you
all right
all right and
everyone killed
everyone season one flashbacks no season
one flashbacks of 16 just tearing
through three characters
well okay
2021 was safe here to safe
cylinder blades try to quickly swap to
uh
i would say blade in spanish espada de
plata i believe figures there that's
what is your name espada de plata went
for at level 3 but now that's not enough
two nil for no car one more game
first the freeze so yep like you said
silver blades has one more opportunity
to mount this comeback and i feel yeah
the momentum uh is just not in his favor
nope is just so clinical with this team
look at that banana reflect getting the
to him turning this into a potential
two-touch situation as long as he can
optimize this which we know nokia can
interesting yeah maybe try to hold up
there didn't get counted here so
definitely wasn't pressing the button
probably doesn't care though as long as
it gets to hit
wow can't see it
i didn't see anything well i saw it that
kibbu is managed to escape somehow
get to reflect into showtime it's time
to dunk some fools
oh just excuse me
yeah hello yeah
sir fair honest
he's not gonna lose the character for
that okay he's not gonna lose the
character but
yo
yeah he'd be doing what he wants
don't test the war combat man everything
is going look as way man it's quite
impressive
to see how well he's playing on this
expensive spacing here we go at his
finest 6m vanish okay pie star
nope nope
there we go
rain check
and he even gets a cheeky level
at the end
of this noka is looking absolutely
unstoppable right now silver blades
absolutely needs to do work we have
nothing he's nother do anything
in this match
yeah yeah i think he's been oh you know
what no napa don't do anything but the
business partner does
i'll check you on that one you're right
damascus
there we go listen we are we are just
smart we just out of a long lockdown
period we had time to reflect on our
life business and everything and not my
thoughts why don't i outsource my
neutral
this sounds like a good business
decision why would i do neutral myself
when someone else can do it for me and
i'll pay him what half a bar
right
nappa is the uh the saiyan of wall
street he knows
he knows how to invest he knows how to
make money and he knows how to make a
comeback as a character he said doesn't
do too much got a chance to plant the
investment and now he's in the lead with
spark still intact
this is looking much better than what i
would have expected silver blades is
absolutely holding on right now let's
see
if he can put the pressure on that ui
goku there is a spark there are two
characters
and the cyberman is in
u2 has been plotting damascus
get out try to
punish the reflex
now
youtube belongs to me did you not know
did you not know
bitcoins were in that my guy this is
mine now
oh oh you know what you got youtube so
do i
the left arm of the forbidden one
strikes again and that is going to be
down level three yes he wants to
potentially force the spot what's the i
mean it's not it's not the biggest mix
it's more it's more like just pressure
there's potentially a moon jump
into dash if you want
but just goes for a dragon restaurant to
the spark oh my god
claps
man not for 5 hd masses
[Laughter]
he's actually just going through a door
he's like police just running through a
door
let me in and when he gets in you've got
to do with simon coming at the back the
good good homie by silver blade hanging
on bring it to 2-1
is this the start of something great i
was about to say this is an extremely
important game c4 cause luca was playing
so well he looked unstoppable for a
while in the previous match but
somehow silver blades got the comeback
and if he can keep building the momentum
up right now that could be extremely
long but no car gets his opening
yeah
is this starting combo so not too big on
the damaged side but it doesn't really
matter because the situation is kid boo
oh no we did it a little bit too late i
feel and nappa is in neutral
getting clipped by kids basil though
all right sandman down
trying to go for the staircase excellent
one bad challenge by silver blades there
and nuka is gonna get his own
combo but drops it gives a chance oh the
assist is stopping him
no car the momentum is supreme right now
look at look at that
the old key was literally
stand there nicely
snooki gave him the note he said i'm
just gonna wiggle my tail oh sorry my
finger and he's gotta tell but he just
won't he just waited for the wake up and
responded accordingly he's rewarded
silver blade trying to suffer through
his characters to not take too much
damage in his nap up and ginyu is out
here and you knew i feel might have been
a star to show for his tournament run
today and that character is gone
potentially for the last time
all right super dash gonna be there he
has to vanish as well
put mine into the corner
going to plan that uh business partner
as well in there we go
and now it's time to block but no we got
spark smart choice by your nokia just
immediately we can mount them mix is
gonna be oh my god hello
and you know what thanks to silver
blades for not sparking on the kid
booming he held firm
i respect noka attempting the counter
but
silver blades went for something a bit
deeper on this one
and a certain man got schmicks but to
drop by silver blades into the raw tag
that is so unfortunate for him nuka is
going to reclaim the momentum
yeah that could have been his
opportunity
oh my gosh another bait but not
converted
oh my gosh
man had to catch a bus or a train or
something massive my uber's leaving me i
had to go but he's still got the
positioning the corner is getting
oppressed by nasa's back right now
we don't do that here
he was brought to destroy me you say
yeah not smart but he goes for a long
combo so he destroys the spark
nice pad that platyada
silva blades
will wake up level three we don't
respect out there a ton of new life
there oh no he gets the opening that's
what can he kill
i think he can if he gets third five
then yes that is gonna be so much meter
building he is dead damascus man said
you know what i'm not just gonna get rid
of goku i'll get rid of vegeta as well
let's go i played it over time double
shift all right let's see both of the
players now they gave a lot to each
other on this niceness movement from
luka he's got a ton of meter as well
that was absolutely amazing and he is
going to get that nappa out put kibbu in
and now to 1v2
that was such a ginyu brain
reaction
and response to the vanish the ied to to
get a punish
what a block young man
no supernatural time
we got mystic balls out there
let's go for the extension
soft knock down keeping the pressure on
nope vanish on vanish
luca is trying to completely put him in
jail but no
massive stuff like he said yeah i've
been a second dual combo he is
he said
wow
c4
no way
oh no punish oh my god he actually ah
what's happening you could have killed
nuka do not regret that one because the
punch is coming at you no car had the
killing combo got stopped by his assist
and he's giving a golden chance to see
the blade that would be massive for
silver blades
can you imagine if super blades can
bring this back nokia's gonna be so
tilted he might be leaning off his chair
right now but he's got no bar i don't
know if silver blades can get in safely
on you i mean you as priests
strong with the normals damascus
one touch oh the jump five s is going to
be the one to take the win loka
what's the scouter saying c4
no because no because power levels
clutch
that's two times
two times silver blades was always going
to make a comeback and the ui
just he said look i cost 4.99
i'm i've got your bag i've got your back
marker i got it don't worry don't worry
that was an incredible set
noka
taking silver blades down
moving forwards
to this loser's final
against kasuga c4 today
you know what is what two days actually
it it's not a tournament that's meant to
qualify someone it's a tournament that's
meant to set up the next three weeks on
the french scene because right now this
is what's happening right let's let us
let us review
let us re-review
the way
the points are currently set up
right kane
let's take a look at the points
together
kane was first with 145 he got fifth so
he got 45 points he's at 190
right silver blades had 105 he got
fourth with 70 so he got 175 he's still
behind kane
all right
no car right now he's guaranteed a
minimum of 100 points so he will be
ahead of kane
right now all three of these players
will be ahead of kane but depending on
who wins because kane only has 190
because he already has sorry martin 90
there isn't a scenario considering these
three where the winner is guaranteed a
qualifier noka winning would be the best
for him at least because you will get a
280
but
there are still a solid amount of
tournaments remaining because the french
tears have been at it
and the entire
entire
possibilities are
the endless everyone can still qualify
right now that's absolutely crazy that
is the best mathematical
like
the best mathematical like ending that
we could get today
you couldn't write this if he was right
on the storyline we couldn't write it
better than this like uh like you said i
think if uh
kasuga's fourth i believe so far so even
if they win it they're like you said
gonna go over uh kane
and you said this earlier kane kind of
wants restaurants are in right now right
because he's got the least amount of
points yeah so when he goes uh above him
when veteran goes above kane at least
he's not that far behind him yeah is
that essentially vesper kasuga winning
is ideal for kane noka winning keeps
things doable for both kane and silva
base columbus you'll be still in the mix
right kane and silver blades will want
no car to lose now right
that's what they want because kasuga
overspring winning he keeps them in a
very solid situation noka winning keeps
kane in makes silver blades
in trouble
but still almost doable so it's still
completely open this absolutely coolest
top three is there and the players are
ready we are about to have the losers
final
noka
versus
kasuga
aino first two three and i believe when
i saw them playing last time at galaxy
explosion which the french weekly i
think kasuga won last time i can't
remember
i watched them playing in
i think it was grand finals as well that
day
i think it was the grand finals and the
stream was third that day
and
i think so i'm not entirely sure i need
to review this but these two of course
they know each other they play each
other uh i will i will definitely we'll
we'll talk i think
we'll we'll talk i think on tuesday we
might do a a point review for all of the
regions to see what's happening
[Music]
versus kasuga
first two three
who will join this play in grand finals
man oh my gosh and castle obviously
from winning side had to play a few less
games no for is you know on fire right
playing games back to back getting those
w's losing early on from loser's side
but the castle got reactions
it's gonna be hard to break him right
now oh never mind just hope that he
drops and he does the message yeah oh
yeah all right gets the pick up
and let's see
that is kefla in the corner and the
pressure is going to be in kepler
blocking and the j that was the smartest
hairdryer
[Music]
classic behind the kid brew assist
you're so scared you hold down back and
you're not ready for the dragon rush the
doctor br the doctor hand escaping
kick to the back that's great
level one anoka is gonna go
in
ridiculous right now not gonna lie like
he's when he gets momentum he looks
extremely hard to stop
yeah he's turned up for sure but right
now
gonna go into the 18
left right situation take him around the
corner i love this level three up boots
are going to connect but what site
whoa
and man local just comes out swinging
after the spark oh
three sparked combos this is a twitter
upload if i've ever seen one look at
that damage the mask cause he's got two
assists on that is this brown break are
we calling todd on discord
level
oh no
immediately
gets that android 21 out and it's
annuity with the pressure now
nice empty jump that's a deadpool sign
for gojita kasuga got he got some time
to think of course
uh because he got absolutely destroyed
in that windows final and at least he
got enough time to think about you know
his gameplay before coming back to this
one
very true yeah best room and they've got
very similar teams right best friend and
nokia and we've seen them fight each
other so yeah maybe the investment warm
up has helped castle go in this matchup
nice that was damascus
the run under wait
pasigo's
that hurts
that actually hurt that actually hurts
all right let's go
that is going to be
a mix behind this all saying sides
that's going to be reflected trying to
barrier that was gutsy by kasuga he
tried he tried
to get his brain bigger i mean you see
android 18's five head she was built for
that
yeah yeah but not to block it though
again with the cross up yeah the
forehead's too big man can sit all day
every day and no car if he can finish
this combo
should be taking the first game of this
step
off the wall
into acid rain
nuka with a one year
over casual right now
strong start but kasugawa is showing a
bit
of a better play
at the end of this one so definitely uh
okay for kasuga but he needs to avoid
giving noka too much momentum right now
let's see yeah
yeah that uh
i feel
so thinking back on what noka did with
the uh the potential todd would you say
a toad sorry
he has to wait for kid boo level one to
bring him back down but i don't know if
he was gonna in that situation but
forget about that like asuka has is
going you know what ammar took the l but
now one just w's let's go
all right let's go on this one oh we're
gonna block we're gonna block castle
guys in the corner waiting there's no
assist on luka sides and the dragon rush
lands kasugawa was not ready
[Music]
hopefully he's going to be ready for oh
he brings in golgi are now okay
interesting we're waggling fingers we're
leveling up the freaking crap
oh no i think he wanted to block and he
jumped by mistake that happens a bit
more sometimes when you panic a bit you
do a back instead of backhands
mg's
yeah that's unfortunate taking a grip of
damage long time and knockdown but
sparks and i kind of agree kasich
definitely plays better with the whole
squad on deck
imagine pressing buttons but the
barriers say no
imagine playing 4.99
pressing buttons and then this
five-head lady comes out with a barrier
completely spoils your fun puts you in
the corner and you still get a left
right
oh same sides oh and the super dash
gonna open him up as well noka gets to a
build meter with that spark activation
and put that andrew dated into the
corner
i like it i like it
he's cooling out
oh that is not fake though yeah okay so
this this basically beats normal vanish
but but kasuga forgot that noka was
still in spark so he could do empty
vanish if you do normal vanish kefla
catches the normal vanish and and just
like gets the damage of this but because
he didn't know he did empty vanish he
could still block it and punish
right right
oh and he has to try to vanish her
challenge after vanish maybe maybe
holding up or didn't get back dash
potentially that dropped but it's okay
[Music]
okay
nope
nope nope
nope
nope
hell awesome it's interesting but pastor
just got no time to think about that
he's just going to take the damage
all right
escapes as well and thus he's going to
pick that 21 up
luca
should be able to get the double kill
actually the happy birthday is wished
have a great day
c4 meeting you
wait no let me say four goals
he's gonna get
he's gonna get the w as well as my
career
on a thin line that is worth me
two girls one combo you see it ninten
catches no car has
played out of his mind this tournament
uh from the last game losing to vesper
and like we said playing a very similar
team
he has come back with a vengeance
yeah
exactly it's like
i am just i'm seeing peak no car right
now of course i mean
for a while noka was was pretty much top
two in france you know like definitely
like a lot for like the top two top
three and stuff and then i think like
with the rise of like kaiden yasha and
the guys and stuff noka started to like
go a bit down on the rankings and and
i'm seeing shades of of top two noka
coming back up right now uh kasuga
it's looking long i know that kasuga was
working on a super saiyan forgoji team
and it looks like he's gonna go for it
that is the team
kasuga will try and survive with can he
stop
the onslaught that is noka or
will we get a run back
no carrots is very in grand finals
gonna be interesting but yeah i
definitely think this is nice to see
from noka because people don't know he
used to play uh
pokey black
mr rose
so this team was like
in the waiting room for him yeah
still be able to go for a time at the
moment kasuga that super saiyan fogita
is looking all right watch out and
straight to the spark that's a very
early sport for noka oh no he got the
pickup but you need to believe in your
five lls you're playing gojita right now
kasuga just 5l
yeah don't hesitate
to let it rip
never mind he is definitely taking a
page out of no facebook right getting
knocked back from staff or spanish to
everyone going straight back in don't
let your opponent have any reprieve
you're a bad man
lick off the light let's go back
together he has nothing to lose he is a
dog will be back to the wall oh no oh no
oh no
he did not at least get the full uh
happy birthday but he's gonna be able to
tag that kojita out turn off blue life
to recover
he's not actually dead nah
uh
he's got a lot of bar but i don't think
it will be oh yeah
i think he survives this
the five
the oaky though that's the big question
at all
apparently
no key is the best approach in that
situation just windy punching who needs
oki
when you can pretend you're doing goku
let's go this air okay
we just pretend we don't do it here
all right look one right now nope
[Applause]
you need to wait and get hit by kibbu
you need to guard cancel watch cloud's
video guys
i personally watched it and i won't
apply anything cloud say so when i lose
i can still say kid boo is too good but
you know
the graves always
but nokia was clearly painting this
anyway that's not a big
yeah just just like watch clouds this
video so you know but then when you lose
just pretend you haven't watched it
that's about all noka at the moment
c4 how do we stop noka right now dude
i kinda already want to speak about talk
about this spring grand finals but
casual guy is having all trouble in the
world
yeah this was uh
this didn't turn out well for casual
right
basically just lost spark
on
probably one of his best characters i
mean he's 18 is definitely up there but
he's 21 puts in a lot of work
and now back against the wall not in a
good way this though because
how is he going to open up yeah he's
got nothing to fear now right he's got
three characters he's too up in the set
why is he not going to challenge every
opportunity he gets
yep absolutely
you got a ton of time to make it work
and kasuga oh no he did not believe in
this one you know what we do it again
barcelona
we're making it work
mix
oh i i saw the counter
yep he
was too he was too deep in the forest
man he was he was dripping in the sauce
thinking oh man i'm going to bake this
and
it just didn't work out cassie could try
to big brain it
not today
unfortunate man from winner's side as
well i mean he's still gonna get a lot
of points uh just not enough to you know
maintain a higher place and as no car
someone who was already in heaven is
going to go even further
i cannot believe what i'm seeing right
now with no with a
with no carbon no car looks absolutely
unleashed
in this and he is going to
reach grand finals
in the run back of two days of the
second game we had today
the stream he took noka down 2-1 earlier
now he needs to win another first two
three against noka or noka has to win
two first two threes
against
uh this game that is extremely close and
just to mention right like
kasuga with his third place
he is going to get
100 points
uh which puts him at
137
which is still a
potential qualifier but difficult
if the stream wins there is still a bit
of a chance
uh yeah yeah but but it's still like
there's still hope for this one so
casual third
silver blades fourth
the grand finals decided guys is going
to be the run pack from that winner
semi-final
with
vesprin
in winners
and noka in losers remember
noka has to win two first two threes
that's uh
man you've got to think about the
journey right like casagar beating kane
first game so they were the first game
on stream
beats kane must have been feeling
extinct and then yeah just kind of
crumbled after that maybe it was having
to wait so long right being put on ice
between the matches losing three zero
the vesper in and then three zero to no
car
still came third though still came third
so like damascus said still got quite a
few points 135 i believe it was but yeah
this is the run back from the second
game we have the semi-finals
and
very very similar teams very similar
play styles and no car has
had the losers run of a lifetime the
people that he had to avoid and beat
down in that shark tank
yeah he he must be feeling some type of
way he must be feeling ready warm a
vestment just sitting there like i'm on
the phone man no one's been able to
touch me especially you because i've
already beat
what you're saying now you're tired
you've got no sensory beans and you've
got to reset the bracket
with my team basically come on man yeah
come on man longer but let's see this
cream has played absolutely ridiculous
so far today and let's see if we can
keep going it's grand finals
of today's
tournament the 200 points on the line
nuka in losers facebook on the winner
side let us see
which one
of these two wins the entire tournament
today and backs themselves an entire 200
points that only like
150 anyway for the winner there for the
loser of this which is still strong but
we won the 200.
indeed and like you said
kane probably tuned on vesperin just for
the results but
no cut definitely won't want that right
want to get that don't want to get the
result against someone who beat him
looking pretty good for him now as he
takes to do to town the golgi are doing
a lot of work here
oh okay okay okay you're no car
he's
in momentum mode right now the most
important thing for this prim is to
claim the momentum that's going to be
the objective
yeah wow he was swinging at nothing
offensive space in my guy but noka ready
navigate through
the peril that was on the ground from ui
gets to put him in the corner oh reflect
me my guy and now you die
brown bread
[Music]
you know what yo that that five l i
[Music]
let me see the two and frame q again
police
no monkey poor
nice answer you are so ready for that
command grab no car about to get the
extension and put that zebra in the
corner what a start
very clean yet goes to level one
wow
[Music]
ouch
he said
second hit hold my boots
taste my yeezys bro don't try and sneeze
on me
ass i've never seen a button beat that
never seen him
is that is this what france has been
missing out on this is the power of
zebra oh double backlash though that's a
powerful and hard read for nokia as the
maximum recovers
from the broly kindness that just
appeared on our screens i am
i am shook
this is what i am
i am
right
that's what i just witnessed oh no okay
press the buttons don't take bottoms man
be working man all the time all the time
demons versus evil
true
starts that long journey towards six
entire games
by getting the first one it's one nil
okay there's one
and
two more then three more
that match
i feel it's not going to be easy for
nokia it's just not going to be easy
right he's going to have to battle
real hard but it's doable he's seen the
chinkiniyama and now he just has to
abuse it
this is the problem with playing similar
teams like
your opponent knows what you're capable
of he knows the gap so you've got to
take a little bit more on the wrist side
but i just didn't wake up five oh
damascus yeah you know what if your meat
is gonna be made out of tofu i'm not
gonna believe in them and i'm cool
all right
yeah no cow is not ready for this one
and we are taking ui goku in right now
not gonna be enough to get the kill
anyway straight to the spark early spark
from luca
this pin can be happy but this could be
flag but no gets opened up
yo spark didn't want any of the
shenanigans oh no he gets [ __ ] oh my
food is going
wild that was moving besides i was like
no
no no i don't need to my character
doesn't
[Music]
punch keeps him in the corner with a
super dash oh you just reflect and i
take your life
all right another strong start by nokia
this game the more we go
the smaller of a margin for error you
have a look at this another bad reflects
noka every single decision he's taking
right now
is a good one
yeah he's making this one look a lot
more comfortable wow he knows about the
reflected web he basically invented it
he's been playing kid boo aka food from
day one
and how he goes this is a showcase
damascus i don't know if it's even fair
to call it a match no car is just being
a demonstration of how to play this team
absolutely it's looking ridiculous it's
zebra's anchor of course the [ __ ] oh my
god
attempting to use the armor against the
keyboard assist was smart but there were
way too many hits for this one luka is
going to try this good block for mervis
in but the back super dash works
good zoom tight gets the ground
confirmed
not much damage but it is all adding up
to assist on deck as well
wow he woke up with absolute aggression
brutality magic wake up my [ __ ]
the
noka is ex sweating man
noka is in
absolutely massive confidence and he's
not giving this cream an inch
to even try that is a two-nil with all
three characters still alive
from noka
and and he knows right now like he needs
to stay in the zone if i was i was about
to say that what was this we would go
back to lobby yeah
pull him off pull him off
i respect that like he read my mind take
some time if you have other teams i mean
you do have our teams anyway but if you
are chance teams think about it but at
the moment
the first rule of order for this film is
get some control get some momentum grab
something because at the moment
the two matches were completely playing
in nokia's hands
yep
yep yeah he
he needs to get some fans not for him
but to cool down local right now because
he is on fire literally he's been
running from the first l he took from
western in losers he's just been smoking
opponent after opponent and now vessel
you can't be another victim you can't be
the person who gets his weight because
locus is trying to take you down you've
got to fight back yeah and that's a
strong start right now obviously looking
a bit better but he's not getting much
damage anyway these are uh not worrying
moments and you know what noka is just
gonna go for this one
ouch
yeah squeezing out all the damage goes
for a soft knock down catches the uptake
reflects four tanks no for wise blocks
and just starts to script again but the
blocks
it's the lamau he was only good for so
long
all right
look luca looking
more like himself right now
and let's see if we can get that oh my
god he challenged have you seen the
confidence that man shows right now he
challenged ui goku's 5ll who does that
he feels invincible
this is literally
oh no
nothing used to be like this off life i
remember this guy
he would do the most ridiculous things
with the most confidence and you would
feel like damn am i that obvious am i
that bad
he is so good at dissecting people's
options and making you think that you
don't know how to play the game
absolutely i'll whisper him getting some
momentum putting that trigger triggering
to the corner that's not the situation
where he can kill i believe he's gonna
get the extension he's got three bars
they're not gonna kill him he's another
touch straight to the spark from no cans
he's gonna chase him into the corner the
2l
opening the kid boo and the stream
in trouble
he has turned up more than 50
doesn't get the dragon rush
gets hit by the ex ball but no confirm
what is happening
oh no
that was that was a confident
right arm of the forbidden one
oh no he's got the same part of the
combo
broly putting kakarot
all right another opening
noka has only lost one character over
the last three games by the way that's
his ui goku on this one level three
it's time for the big snake speaks
double dash ah double dash it is there
we go that's a dead zebra
yeah keeping it nice and simple
using the tools given to ssj4 for the
double iads
and that is gonna
make him a dead z broly he's gonna yell
at him oop in the building take him out
and at least one more pounds of
restaurant and
one more character away from no car
resetting the bracket
i must say this is an absolute statement
from new camera
like
it's kind of stupid good though like how
ridiculous he's been
throughout this loser's bracket front
and there we go this movement making it
work and this game is saving spark for
losers brackets as the bracket
is now reset
no car
wins three nil
after the losers bracket we go
a final first three
for grand finals and for the 200 points
but how
at this point
what do you do against zuka
[Music]
man
you have to re i think you have to just
like rethink about what you did the last
time you fought in uh because obviously
they played it was 2-1 but what nokia's
doing is
it is more like a confidence thing more
than anything i don't think he's doing
anything particularly uh accountable in
game when he presses the button he just
puts his chest behind it he's actually
just smashing his pad with his chest
he's not even using his thumbs and
fingers anymore yeah he believes in
every option he takes and we saw in that
last game right when best friend went
for stuff it was all like blue combos
and then late super dashes he wasn't
committing he didn't put a ring on
anything he did and
i feel nocus just going like i've got
nothing to lose i'm fine from losers
you have to be scared of me now
yep exactly all right let's see the
start this time the first opening goes
to bespin let's go
up back
hit with the end though vestrin and this
is more like we saw the last game but he
dropped the combo and he starts to save
the ube
that's a good save anyway oh not gonna
fuse the combo
room getting the confirm
off the table and again getting a hit
but no confirm and man like mocha is
gonna take you to town for those
mistakes
is that dead that's dead
yep
brown
red he is out of here
that was quick that was efficient
look up once again takes the lead but
there is still a spark on this side
[Music]
yeah this is true this is true that is
the uh
the mechanic that can definitely bring
him back into the game but first he
needs to get a hit
okay i wanna know what's happening
because noka is completely overriding
five lls today like autocombo does not
work against him what what is happening
i i i don't know what's happening but i
prefer this style from bespoke he is
committed now now he's going i'm not
waiting i'ma do it
yep level 2 should
strong one for the first game of this
second sense
fighting back here's oop
best moon just jumping into space nice
puts him in the subway between a rock
and a hard place gets to confirm
puts him in the corner
oh my god
wait how are you so warm
oh caitlin
that was that was the man who knew
yeah i thought it was
free all day
all day the bibliotheque
god
no
let him know we both paid 4.99 for this
character my dudes you both paid the
same amount i'm gonna do the same thing
you do
now hold this present we both have a 5l
that's great at handing the else over
the frame kill into the victoria station
there i mean you know it's a good lock
it's a good luck situation 5l or command
grab and remember that if you face it's
your face zebroni blocking 5l
means you're in a mixed situation
right you press 5n if you open and block
you're like okay cool let me mix him now
it's a it makes up his oldest time
itself
yeah i mean he probably wanted to stop
the 2s game but nokia's shown time and
time again if he gets knocked back by
spark or vanish or whatever he's trying
to get straight back in there he doesn't
want to be far away from you
that's that's not how he plays the game
that's not what he wants to do and
that's not how he wins
all right 1v1 one touchy on both sides
supernatural
oh no that's the bad vanish but
thankfully noka had committed
to a super dash there yeah oh my gosh
no double sneeze
j s into heavy ball bang my chest
[Music]
this guy
kid fizzle
clutches out for no car once again and
now he's actually in the lead
two more games and he takes 200 points
that's the best case scenario for
norfolk today man
the way the way the rankings panned out
give him the absolute strongest option
right now let's see
oh the grime it's in the low behind the
ui assist
and
esprin
showing signs of life
and we saw this last time damascus
sparking to keep
alive yeah and it's working out for him
oh no
all right
sends man down extending a bit more
all right let's let's i have a game idea
c4
let's go let's go do you have super dash
challenge
oh wow
i'll keep an eye out
we need to make it work straight
oh i like it nice way to bring in kid
buu getting a little bit
of a mix there as well
overhead gets blocked
it reflects
z broly
bringing in the black up
best brain this is different this is
this investment i think he woke up
someone d ended and said oh you know you
need to win this set anyway okay
oh my god
this is the simplest mix but it's so
good
it's so good you need you're committing
something
oh can he kill now i think you need one
i think he's alive yeah he's alive
unfortunately
see my fist from a distance from talk to
my hands
and he's not finished yet
vesperan he has
returned to the tournament he is pointed
to no car
ignorance
look
he's
there
it work remember guys that these guys
they faced each other in windows
semifinal and this cream is the one who
won
muso tensei we got the counter that's
gonna be the kill this team is sending
that choi goku out and he's down to
by himself will the stream finally get
one point
oh he gets clipped by the ube though so
it's not over yet he's still got one
very healthy zebra lee but yeah this
vesperan this is
him looking a lot more confident than he
was in the previous four matches four
matches have gone past and no car is
looking to get another two two eight two
eight challenge still active
which you remember achievement
achievement to unlock
steel oh no punish
yes
let's go
it is done
but it's not killing
yeah it is
[Music]
so
apparently you can catch damascus on
metaphy because he's actually coaching
people what's to do he said he wants to
see it and he got to see it
i have i have never popped off so much
at a supernatural situation in my life
[Laughter]
and it paid off maybe that maybe that
was the thing that
uh bespoke needs to look out for because
they both do it right they both have
such a
terrifying point character that super
dashing for full screens are things that
you're just so scared of you just block
or reflect though yeah
all right
there's him staying strong this time
sending okay to the corner you wake up
buttons man
wake up buttons
it's like they can't hear the jazz in
the background because they've got no
chill
no whatsoever
listen to the listen to the saxomaphones
my guys come on we're chilling
we are happily chilling enjoying the
music pressing buttons
and he's putting man down nuka is at
level 2 right now and the raw tag
still not
scoped sniped by no cars gonna keep the
pressure on that ui goku or he tried to
escape that could have been big
yeah that could have been mature damage
it's still gonna get a little bit right
now and he might opt to go for the level
up technique let's find out never mind
he's gonna spend the level two on this
level three all right double dash fuzzy
mt nothing
[Music]
all right
vanish
[Music]
back on the leads looking to reclaim the
momentum that this thing stole for him
do you hate no super dash that's what
i'll have to see let's go
oh my god he gets the happy birthday as
well
but the two h stuff that happened
happening sad that he did not uh just go
for a spark there but
he didn't want to uh didn't want to kill
i mean that was just a five and start so
he would have been able to kill that
first time for vegeta so not necessarily
uh useful
try to catch the air tech
stays firm and blocked now goes for the
aggression 2h
that was a weird decision from this
because the fighting decision but he's
taking it right now you're going to
block
that's cheap that looked intentional as
well that looks real intentional i think
that he just pressed yellow that moves
him out to the corner right
i don't know about these dark parts that
you speak of i don't know about them
i think so
like it's a panicking food from the
stream that just like put him out of the
corner
and he did not realize
and just like that nokia sent that to a
goku out and now
it's zebraly with spark so noka has to
do the combat good luck
i mean this this is that broly rises
good to hate i guess that was the anya
for the jm
not gonna kill are we going to spend
three bars which is going to keep the
pulling up
what is the choice there we go
oh my god he blocked the spark and
immediately challenged this one
no car going for the longest combo he
can do
just to
let this park run away
what does he do here i mean he's got the
bar if he wants to vanish in or he could
use the meter to
get him with a dash
options options and he doesn't have to
look for spark now wow all aboard
the bullet train
that was the same crosstalk now that was
the sequel
drizzle the sauce my guy
back away oh yeah he's just keeping that
zebraly out
yeah just walk
just
just show him
can he get the third ball
yes he can
and that's dead
noka
is on too much points
to get 200 points and honestly c4 not
only will he get 200 points that
outcome
this exact top five in order
right having silver blades fourth
and kane fifth is the absolute perfect
stars align scenario for noka
to win and to have the strongest option
to move forward
and be in paris for the original finals
in december
one more game
needed but this team is going to be the
one
opening the favorites there
yeah
hopefully vestment doesn't run out of
steam but good dragon rush on the
reflect
not going to be able to kill probably
you see broly for some
pressure
that's away you decide to want to play
neutral noka but hasn't been working out
too well for them as of late or maybe
they've got a new game plan on deck
i mean he actually did a full screen
super dash
that's how
that's how both of them are confident
that no one is 28 today
no accountability no remorse just press
the button
and when my team's too strong for you to
even consider to hatching it right now
locals showing the strength of ui as he
mixes up this kid
he's got a
hm i don't think he'd killed he needed
five bars here i think
yes he's got that oh yeah i was looking
at the wrong side yeah he's dead
oh
[Music]
and once again
putting a step in paris
damascus some people say
frame day it was a social construct i
think it's a social contract
and local just opted out he said i'm not
listening to any of this i don't care
what you think
i believe it's my turn
let's see
let's swim now putting some pressure on
look at this that uh ui goku needs to do
some work
goes for z broly and you know it frame
kill 2m
into 5l or command grab have fun
good reflect
please
[Music]
that was actually really sick yeah
stomping them
okay what is the barrier going to do
against my far bell
that's that's all that with you
yeah
i think that's dead
level two one three
two
into one
into three
bastards
no car
one character away from being the
champion
and bagging these 200 points
pretty big of a hill for him to climb if
he can do it still got sparked like i
said oh no puts himself between
kid buu and goji are not a good look so
far not enough bar here to kill but
this is looking dire yeah we take those
yeah we take those finish him
no oh my god this cream that was a
golden opportunity for you to come back
straight to the counter
all we need to do
is to go for that level one
and that's it you will never need
another one noka
will be today's tenkaichi master event
champion
200 points
in the pocket for noka 150 points in the
pocket
for this spring what
an
incredible loser's bracket run by no
carmen ever since he was put in that
loses brackets
he just powered up
yeah
yeah that was uh
he was journey right
lost the vesperon beat everyone else in
lower loser's bracket to get back to
vesper and reset the bracket
still one that you can't want anything
more from losing your first game in top
eight what a absolute solid run
and does it against someone with a very
similar team just
really showing dominance in his kid boo
play and his ui
three nil
three one
i mean look at nokia right he lost the
semi-final
and then tuning over junior three one of
the
over silver blades three nil over kasuga
three little breast prim three one he
barely lost the game
he lost like two entire games in all of
this loses bracket front and went all
the way to the win and as we mentioned
because of the way this finished with
kane fifth and silver blades fourth who
were the top two of this
noka was third before today he is now a
comfortable
first as he had 80 points he will now
have 280 that puts him 90 points ahead
of kane
on this
and it is definitely going to be
comfortable all he has to do is place
acceptable in the few tournaments
remaining i'm not saying winning up like
play stop four
and
you will be in paris still do a ball for
pretty much everyone else but no car
pretty much has like one foot in paris
right now
yeah yeah if everything stays like uh
consistent for him with results as long
as he's getting like top eights and
whatnot and maybe like gatekeeping
certain players you might have to do the
uh
the oh man the gatekeeper strategy of
like putting yourself into losers just
to knock out certain people that have
got points he might just have to be
doing that but like you said he's got so
many points around that he's looking
pretty comfortable but yeah he can't
just sit back and let everyone else play
for the point he still has to do a
little bit more work
absolutely noka has a very very strong
option in that qualification there
remember that the regional finals are
all offline
europe one will be on four and fifth
december 2021 the first weekend of
december second weekend of december will
be the usa original finals third weekend
of december will be the japan regional
finals there is
so there are three about three weeks
remaining in the overall circuit as the
uh tenkaichi events close on 14th of
november so exactly three more weeks of
competition and there is one more master
event on this channel that will be next
week at the same time and that will be
the spanish one spain still has to
decide who
will be qualified on this one currently
the top two in spain are miami and
haukas so it's gonna be played uh mostly
between these two but plenty of strong
strong contenders in that region as well
there is carleton in italy scarlet above
mission all of the guys from italy kenya
in portugal plenty of others in spain
it's going to be a hype one but that
will close
today's tournament noka with a massive
win but i want to say congratulations to
the spring man grand finals i don't
think many aside from us who really
follow the french scene would have
expected this
yeah 100 i think
uh the
the placing is definitely not like
uh bad for restaurant it's a bit
disheartening when you lose to someone
who reset a bracket on you and someone
you've beaten but the run before that
was actually phenomenal considering who
ended this tournament yeah absolutely
it's definitely a ridiculous performance
for all of them of course but that will
be it for today guys thank you so much
everyone for joining us today for some
more good dragon ball fighterz we still
have the masters event next week and
then we will be all offline in december
for some like super high level dragon
ball fighterz i cannot wait for this of
course until then guys plenty of
tournaments uh remember to go to the
esports portal to not only sign up but
you can also see the calendar for every
single uh for every single region if you
want to enter to watch or like
everything you can just like check there
and check where is there to be and of
course if you want some more dragon ball
you know it on my channel every tuesday
is wanted we actually have casual coming
this wanted uh this tuesday he will face
yasha in the first seven uh we get mr
popo this tuesday i mean we get all of
the very best you know it is always like
some of the most hype we could get on
dragon ball fighters but that would be
it for today man like c4 for the blast
as always man
yeah man it's uh
it's always been great commentary with
you sorry for people that want a tyrant
i'm a pretty good substitute i must stay
but yeah uh pleasure talking to everyone
in chat commentating some of the best we
have in dragon ball z uh europe one uh
french players showing up so
entertaining with the teams and the play
like
always a pleasure man love this game
loves minnie i'm always good always good
man do make sure you guys follow uh c4 i
am c4 iq on twitter and twitch streams a
lot of dragon ball run the weekly
tournament always around i know it guys
you will see uh the two of us very soon
around dragon ball whether it's like on
my channel on his channel or dragon ball
fighterz we're always out there thank
you everyone for joining congratulations
to noka for the win today i will see you
on this channel next week for spain on
my channel on tuesday or around guys
when dragon ball is there you know we
never too far from me thank you everyone
for joining today much love to noka
we'll see you soon for more dragon ball
fighterz have a great sunday night guys
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i am
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you